Shalom hello hey girl the show is
brought to by the cash has everyone
finance app in the App Store the cash
shop is the simplest way to send to
receive money especially when your
friends o you or when you all of them
ones last time use the cash happen to
buy that kimono deny that cashmere come
on I shared it and made about this
straight out cash whatever use the cash
I'm on some money so she could see me
toilet paper cuz my little town still
got toilet paper we still got sent up
there you paid your mom to send you
toilet paper yeah during their own the
crisis yeah how much toilet paper you
use it over they don't need a lot but
it's like if everybody else is gonna
have something I don't be left out your
mom wasn't gonna sent it for free of
course she was like I like to send it
she's like bitch hit my cash I know you
ain't got it listen you lost shit
easiest way to try and grow your money
in the stock market with our investing
feature with I say our now I'm part of
this company with cash job you can
instantly invest any stock as little as
one dollar
did you know the brokerage services are
provided by Cash I'm investing a
subsidiary of square and member si PC
Benton I have heard well now you know
you don't know and if you don't know now
you know I've been known when you sign
up for cash up and use the promo code
Whitney not only me you instantly
receive $10 but cash up will also donate
$10 to the trevor project an amazing
organization that protects benton from
me yes all they do protective services
to LGBTQ youth across america
don't forget promo code whitney when you
download the cash up from the up store
tada
[Music]
okay pod and the time of quarantine
Taylor and I are gonna make sure we're
six feet apart during this entire
podcast so that we don't get cancelled
so that we don't get canceled by the
internet and attacked by you people I
also would like to clean and disinfect
the tape measure so we're gonna be
exactly six feet apart uh-huh at all
times okay ready this is pretty boy yeah
do it okay I said before we started
recording that I've just been imagining
like the length of my dad's whole body
in between me and other people wait and
I said my dad's dead so he's about this
bad
so that's not ever and then we hugged no
we didn't I try to hug you yet okay yeah
okay that's not bad
we did it six feet boob to boob or face
to face I think I mean it's probably the
same right I'm so glad you guys sold
this I thought you were being dumb and
then it touched my nose and I'm like I'm
actually glad she did that I could both
it both could be happening simultaneous
Here I am we're six feet apart I feel
the need to yell I know I hear you it's
very quiet hey dude oh my god so far
emotionally you're really way more than
six feet yeah oh so far more not ties
with everyone emotionally I I need to be
ready to lose any of you this
emotionally might be the closest I've
been to any one guy sorry about that
it's been 14 days I'm lonely my best
friend I know we were I mean we should
also like anyone who gets mad at us for
podcasting we should publish our text
messages we really win scheduling this
because I was we were both like if
you're not comfortable it's totally fine
but if you're not comfortable it's
totally fine but also
I haven't been anywhere except the
grocery store in 14 days okay I've been
in total isolation for 13 days okay so
and all right and I know some do you
know anyone who said no okay and I've
just been indoors and but if and I have
Lysol and if you think that it's okay
then I think it's okay I mean we were so
careful getting kind of competitive I
was like I didn't I sliced in ten days
you're like 11 days I'm glad she's like
12 days know I've seen one person look I
barely saw someone I would like drag so
hard
yeah but it's interesting because I feel
like bi I watched you I've been watching
your social I'm watching everyone's
social I'm seeing what you're doing I'm
doing the math I'm adding up everything
you're doing I'm looking in the
background or your videos and your hikes
and your photos I'm hearing people off
camera some people are liars
some people think some people are having
their things filled sudden are cooking
I'm like where'd you get that zucchini
oh yeah groceries like but you told me
you haven't left your house in ten days
what are all these fresh squash oh yeah
no you can't live garden no I really I'm
going full like um full Sherlock on
people's photos on their captions with
their fridges I'm like let me see your
fridge yeah yeah that couldn't have
stayed good nope
for 11 days away yeah that cut avocado
I've had that for eight days and it's
still bright green I don't think so and
at this point it's like you couldn't
have even gotten that delivered like
getting groceries delivered at this
point days are over weeks
chiliad at this point ya know it's like
we have to go to the grocery store if we
need more food now yeah and you got a
hope that everyone else is being equally
careful it's actually funny because I we
usually started this podcast asking the
person if we're friends or not we are
now yeah I and I would never say yes
we're friends cuz that would make me
sound psychotic if I came and really
yeah I knew we're friends i watch Easons
middle school like we're great friends
thank you so nuts but now that the world
is on fire I'm like yeah no we're pretty
close there is something funny about us
cuz we were like ships in the night
mmm-hmm we see each other but I I do
appreciate the fact that we've sort of
like circled each other we sort of like
just mutual respectful like hey how are
you
there's been no like do we need to be
best friend like I feel like you're like
me and that you go to the comic store
you get in and you get out yes and you
are someone I reference when people like
you gotta hang out more like you really
you two standoffish and it's always it's
always male comedians who do don't ever
say that to another guy no no that you
really have to hang out and I always go
oh maybe I should and then I go Whitney
never fucking hung out Whitney's doing
great and that's I just I told myself
that for years and I've I stand by it I
do not think you need to hang out but
people probably think I'm a bitch too I
don't know that they do do you think
people think you're a bitch I it's
interesting I think I remember one time
Sarah Tiana really funny comedian who is
on Spade's show now one time she she had
heard puppy she brought her puppy
maverick little boxer puppy to the
comedy store this is like I don't know
five years ago I'd been doing comedy for
like maybe like ten years and I see the
pup you know but could I hold your puppy
and she looked at me like her face was
ashen and I was like what's going on
she's like oh I just I I didn't realize
that you were such a nice person and you
know it took the dog to sort of get me
it's a sort of socialize and she's like
I just had no idea you were this nice
nose she's like I was just like you're
such a bitch and I was like no I'm
scared
yes I'm standing in the hallway scared I
don't want to talk to a male comedian
somewhere there anything I'm flirting
with them I don't want to upset anyone I
don't want it because comedians also as
soon as you start talking it turns into
a roast I yeah my feelings are gonna get
hurt if I talk to somebody there's no
really I just like trying to get in here
work on my jokes and get out yeah you're
gonna make one comment if you stay with
me for years it's not worth it tonight
you're gonna agree with the insult right
oh it's not even gonna be fun for you
cuz I'm gonna go I said that to me in
the car way here yeah oh oh my god now
you sound like my mom like all this dark
shits gonna come up and I I realize that
I think that whether it's me or whether
it's being a woman whatever it is I
think a lot of times when you're just
silent insecure people project onto you
what they think of themselves so you
become sort of
like refractor of like what they think
about themselves and a lot of people
think you're a bitch a lot of people
conflate silence with superiority a
feeling of spirity yes I think that's
true and I will say I think for you it's
probably intensified by the fact that
you are very hot with very sharp
cheekbones like I'm not - whatever but
like I have a soft round face so people
give me the benefit the doubt of being a
good person and so like I just I look
like a lot of white people's cousins so
that she's she's quiet but she's
probably afraid but like even people
think I'm standoffish sometimes so if I
get that I'm sure you got that like
times a thousand I'm glad you brought
this up because I would like to talk
about your face and body please please
do with it so I know because you your
face is unbelievable like you've got a
you have a movie star face from the 30
oh that's untrue but I will take it no I
mean a lot of movies but I I assume this
is what they looked like
yeah just like you're so symmetrical
your eyes are just
you're like a doll you look like a doll
oh thank you all I heard was you look
better in black and white and lower
definition that's all on film and with
scurvy yeah of course that's an eye and
a bonnet covering most of your face well
you know it's so crazy I mean like I had
somebody send me a message on Instagram
that I don't even think I replied -
somebody sent me a messy like I watched
your Netflix special I loved it also we
have similar body types and it just it
means so much to me to see that and I
was like I was like offended and I
couldn't even see what the person looked
like by the way like they had a private
account and their picture was like very
small like have no idea what they look
like I just I hear you are my body type
and I was like you mean like you don't
see that that mic and that it's good I
don't like it just I didn't know how to
take it and then I felt bad for not
taking it well right away and I was like
I had to really sit with myself for like
10 minutes and go am I
problem am I pretty like it's so stupid
that we even think about
welcome to the feedback loop of every
compliment is an insult somehow yeah
always and I remember watching you and
just seeing like how gorgeous you are
and and this is probably not gonna go
well but I just in your hairs down and
you're special you're you have the you
note and you just look so gorgeous and I
was just like oh my god this is just I
it took me so long to not apologize for
being feminine oh my gosh thank you see
and I like my hair's up in the special
but I do have some tendrils down and
that is only because my face is so round
it is if it is all back like it gets I
turn into Charlie Brown really quick
like I have a big head and I know I have
a big head cuz I've told every guy I've
ever dated I have a big head and it's
every single one of them have responded
I love your big head nobody's ever said
it's not that big not even is not that
big not even I think it's fine or normal
I love your big hat say something that's
not gonna land well I thought I was
gonna go but like it matches your body
it does no it doesn't mean it's
proportion it is it's all it's Midwest
Midwest Midwest it's and I'm from
California I don't know how this
happened but I you know I love corn-fed
I Leegin labels as fuck I was so pissed
when Ellen special came out and it was
called relatable like legit so angry no
that was mine I literally remember the
first time I saw your body and times up
on me cuz I could not stop staring it is
undo it like what are you just doing
squats all day what are we doing it
means no I feel like I have to be
careful with squats because I will like
my my bow that's regularly yeah yeah
this is my butt this is so weird to be
having this conversation with you by the
way because for exact like talking about
being feminine on stage and like it
being okay for you to look like a woman
I mean that's like that's because of
comics like you like you are
I watched your specials going like oh so
you can be hot and do this you can like
and it's fine and you can be successful
and I think you were talking about
overcorrecting and starting out really
dirty
I started out super clean interesting
and I think that for me I was trying not
to say oh I was trying not to say
anything
like in a wind or sexual I mean I got a
comment the other day on a tweet that
said like 90% of female comedy is sex
and I went off on this dude before I
blocked him because I was just like are
we still doing this so when I started it
was more like people were getting shit
on female comedians were getting shit on
for being too dirty and too sexual
and if no they were also getting shit on
that do it but if you were really clean
yeah you I got a lot of praise for that
like the first six years that I was
doing stand-up I was cleaning up into
like four years ago and I got so many
compliments I still get them from people
who are like it's so great that you are
not saying vagina every two minutes and
that's even now where I like swear and
I'll do sex jokes and again it's the
round face thing but like if people
really they gave you so much credit for
being really clean and you start to get
addicted to that and it also is like you
want your parents approval there's a lot
wrapped up in yeah yeah I could never
get that no matter what rank either now
but once I once I started like swearing
or telling sex jokes I was like I mean
you're never you're never gonna be what
everybody likes that's what's the point
like why am I trying so hard yeah but I
really resisted it for a long time
because I was like I mean my I did you
were also 20 yeah well I did I also
barely League I was very I was very
young I think if you just cuz you were
26 now
so if you when you first started if you
were doing sex jokes it would be
different to be like wait how old is she
what han with this is it's a different
thing to picture right as well you know
I think that we have to understand that
when we do stand-up we're asking people
to we're
painting a picture for people to
visualize us and I feel like it might
make people lean out a little bit to be
like she's so young why am I thinking
about that and then it brings up their
own pervy stuff and shame and whatever
right I also don't worry about me I
looked 60 when I was 20 so it's also
funny to me because I think I realized
at the beginning when I was so worried
that exuding any kind of femininity or
sexuality that like maybe the women in
the audience would think I was like
trying to take their man or whatever or
like I don't want anyone to get you know
weird or just to bring up any
insecurities what I realize is that none
of the women cared or felt competitive
that was my shit that was me being
insecure because when I was younger I
was so worried that the guys I was
dating if they looked at any other woman
I thought they were like cheating on me
like I I didn't understand that men
could find other women attractive and
not cheat or there wasn't a rejection of
me I was so naive I thought that like
men had to have blinders on and every
woman was a threat to me when I was
insecure so that was my shit all the
women were like we wait you look great
you look beautiful and I was just like
you guys I'm really trying trying not to
hurt you by looking too feminine
we're fine we're okay yeah you're in
la-5 yeah like we dressed up for this -
I hate to break it to you not threatened
by you at all
wearing a backpack you know what I think
oh you know what I will say though even
if people don't feel threatened by you I
do feel like if any comedian looks like
they are trying super hard I feel like
that's a turn-off to people interesting
and I do feel like part of it is just it
a lot of it is coming from your own
stuff like if I leave my hair down do a
set yeah it never happens like I just
did The Tonight Show to promote the
special and the lovely women doing my
hair makeup we're like leave it down it
looks amazing and the set went fine
mm-hmm but I had a full-blown panic
attack when it came out just like what
was I thinking leaving my hair down I'm
like I was not in the pocket like it's a
fine set but it would have been so much
better if my hair were in a ponytail
well because
it's so interesting to me that people
don't know that stand-ups a sport mm-hmm
it's not a modeling company it's a sport
so it's like you're moving around you're
turning you're pretty and you have to
just do whatever you normally do so if
you always wear your hair down onstage
when you do your Tonight Show you're
special
wear your hair down because you're used
to it whatever I would advise against it
for continuity issues but that's just me
but uh don't do something for the first
time when you're recording it yeah you
know and I it drives me nuts because
I've fallen into that trap before and I
did it in my HBO special every was like
wear your hair down and I was like all
right and I was thinking about it the
entire time
I didn't realize how much I bent over it
I've got lip gloss and my hair in my lip
glass it was like I was hair and like it
was just so dumb and I regret it so
profoundly yeah I mean a five minute
late-night said yeah you're trying to
stay still anyway that's right that's
very distracting if you're pacing so for
me okay yeah for my special it was not
even a question yeah yeah like to be
trying to do physical act out there any
other jobs where women have to think
about this that are in sports about
whether your hair can be up or down I
guess like medical stuff you probably
shouldn't be a surgeon with your hair I
don't think any surgeon is going in like
I shouted a do I have to put it up chefs
making your food like but it looks so
cute
yeah it's not a question having a good
hair day I was so stoked when I saw
birds of prey did you see birds of prey
I mean there's a fight scene where
somebody hands another girl a hair tie
that's not a fighting that's really
funny I was so after I saw what's the
brie Larson won Captain Marvel yeah I
literally tweeted can we give some of
these female superheroes hair ties
because this is ridiculous
aliens and shit with their hair down I
just learned the difference between us
between someone with hope your age and
someone my age as you said the brie
Larson movie you thought Captain Marvel
I thought the room
so yeah the room she's in Captain
Harville territory I'm in a room I'm in
quarantine we've all been in the room
for the past 14 days all I could think
about
I watched the room I'm like Alex finally
she has a kid in there with her hey all
these John Goodman is hanging out in the
hallway has any part of you been like I
should have had a kid
No I've been like I'll never have a kid
now you know what's interesting is I did
think like five days ago I was like oh I
should probably get pregnant
Nancy I know how because you have time
you're not working I was like oh
everyone liked it's probably to be like
six to nine months now I'm like oh I can
just bang out a kid like now it'd be the
perfect time and you're just gonna hope
the hospitals are fine bye thank you you
could do a home birth I could do a home
birth I could do a tub birth but the
promise I would need sperm in my vagina
oh yeah just hard to arrange from six
feet away I mean if they if they
quarantined for 14 days and they
definitely don't have it and they come
here you know more you know person I
trust that's done that is your boyfriend
this awkward so and that's how we're
gonna be making money are you gonna take
one for the team at six months we're
gonna be loaning him out for breeding
let's see how supportive of other female
comics you really are let's see if
you're a girl's girl Taylor can I fuck
your boyfriend nine months how much
seriously how much if you had how much
money for me to have sex with Sam let me
how much where it wouldn't be weird just
give me give me one more month and let's
see how much work gets canceled and let
me ask you these cool oh you can give me
a mother I'm like you know I need I need
a break I will hit your red mouth how
long have you two been together
six months it I would say three or four
times a day
I think about couples that been have
been together for six months in
quarantine
yeah and I'm curious how it's going cuz
you're learning the rubbers hitting the
road I mean here's the thing we have
been long-distance New York to Los
Angeles since we started seeing each
other
mm-hmm so
we got close really fast right right
because you're spending so much time on
the phone on face so prolong distance
because the sex doesn't confuse things
you can write it to know each other yeah
tickets no absolutely I mean this second
night we talked on the phone we talked
for seven hours we were on the phone
from midnight to 7:00 in the more
I didn't go but my bank account went
down and so we've just been going back
and forth and so honestly this has been
good kind of great for us which we say
yeah we've been waiting yeah never mind
the body in the streets but no we have
never gotten to live with each other
longer than like five days yeah in a row
oh and we get along very well and we're
just like best friends so it's been like
kind of great for us to the point where
we feel very guilty were there any red
flags with him that have since been
deactivated before quarantine yeah like
was there anything that was like I don't
know about that and then you were like I
can live with it or anything
you know I don't know I have gotten
really good at letting things go because
you kind of have to that is actually
like the most fucking bad as good I've
gotten really good at letting things go
cuz you kind of have to yeah I mean
there's no other choice at this point
yeah I assume this is probably what it
was like for our grandparents who got
married that's right in the 40s at 12
yeah where you made a choice and then it
was like I cannot leave you and then you
had two options it was like this guy or
this guy yeah this guy I think is my
distant cousin so let's go with this guy
right exactly and I don't have any money
where am I gonna go yeah
I literally this is there's a real thing
that happened the other day I woke up
and I said I had a nightmare
that you cheated on me and he goes that
couldn't even happen right now he's like
that is impossible what the fuck that's
not why you that's how I use
is that why you're not cheating yeah
because we're in lockdown I've tried
it's just it's a whole thing
he's like I'm too scared of germs like I
would never stick it in anyone that
wasn't you because I don't know where
they've been
I mean he was like obviously no I would
never cheat on you please like I'm just
saying like it's also the pandemic yeah
doesn't help is very funny but also I
was like how dare you this is ridiculous
there's also like I met this girl I
think I fell in love with her she's got
a lot of toilet paper right I'm she's
not close to as hot as you oh I'm sorry
I said how dare you and made you think
about touring there you I totally have
gone numb I didn't hear it I blocked it
out really yeah I must have blocked it
out I didn't hear you saying and you
remember how it feels doing stand-up no
neither cannot forgot I completely
forgot so what's so funny about all this
is that when comedians go back to
touring we're gonna be bad so bad so bad
at comedy rusty
comedy is like bodybuilding you have to
work out every single day mm-hmm we're
not we're gonna be rusty we're gonna not
have done comedy for a year we're gonna
reimburse with dad jokes but everybody's
gonna be so starved for nights out and I
think that they're gonna be afar will be
lower yeah well you know it's gonna be
like going to see a youtuber live
everyone's like you know what we're just
glad we saw them here's the good news
you guys won't be breathing on each
other cuz we won't be making you yeah
you don't have to worry about spreading
the virus cuz your mouth will be closed
the whole show should I be laughing into
my elbow we're far apart
it's oh we are yeah get it back guys
feet apart there we had oh I love that
I'm match my shirt with my tape measure
so have there been any quarantine
specific fights besides him cheating on
you and your dreams I shouldn't have a
kid huh no I don't think so yeah maybe
you could adopt that what I was thinking
but really really sanitize it having
like maybe like hose it down out front
keep it takes me away from me yeah that
to me is probably the amount of distance
I want from a child maybe I should get a
kid from foster care or adopt a kid
because I'm a big adopt having your own
credit the
point it's kind of like buying a dog
from a breeder yeah I feel like I should
adopt but yeah now might not be the time
or might be the perfect time we don't
know how long does it go on I don't know
I I mean we were talking about it before
we started recording but it is it's hard
to be on phone calls like planning your
next year yeah
tour dates yeah and kind of and everyone
going we hope this is the plan yeah
because no one no one else could be the
plan two weeks ago we were like marches
canceled yeah yeah yeah and now it's
like summer is dead 20 22 yeah yeah yeah
and then there's also the question of
when we come back is are people gonna
have a bunch of money to spend you know
and will there still be PTSD around
groups or people gonna want to go into
you know venues who knows I you know
we're gonna stay positive about this but
I do want to ask you because we are
virtual strangers that have a lot in
common
yes we're very similar I will take it
sorry that's probably insult no no that
was great are you kidding we're like the
same person I'm like how much money I'm
like we're like the same person really
easy no I do find it very interesting
that we both have been engaged and are
no longer yes which I was not going to
bring up until you did because I think
you've been more private about it
then I have I did material about it in
my special about calling off my
engagement because it happened months
before I filmed it happened after I
found out I got the special and before
we shot it yeah so I'd like write some
material pretty quick do you feel like
you have whatever's going on in your
special has to reflect what's going on
in your personal life or else you're
being like dishonest or in Congress yeah
I mean I've done one special so whether
I film a special Whitney I mean you know
HBO versus Netflix it's all so different
you feel like a phony like like if if
I'm doing material on stage that isn't
true anymore do I feel like a phony yes
yes yeah me too yeah I need to you know
such a bummer I literally Mike can we
just stay together for another six
months I can keep doing this bit kind of
yeah you if I can rework it then we can
go our separate ways
my friend who's engaged yeah it's not
great because there were some bits about
him that I lost on Conan yeah yeah we
got vine we got him yeah got him down
they're not going on Netflix
yeah they got on Conan oh fantastic so
then they get on Instagram they're gay
they're getting out there we got him
it's all that matters fantastic but yeah
I mean I
we had like we were breaking up
gradually over two months uh so two
months is actually not that long I'm
surprised I mean we were only I got you
were gonna say two years no I mean we
were only together for like a little
over a year okay I mean it was so silly
to be engaged that soon do you think
you'd still be together if you weren't
engaged I hadn't gotten engaged
no you're do you think we would have
broken up if you hadn't have gotten
engaged
oh I don't know I thought about that I
thought about that when it was like
immediately after we broke up I was like
if we weren't engaged and the things
that happened that made me go this is a
huge issue and we're not engaged in
anymore
yeah if those things that happened when
we weren't engaged maybe it I don't know
it could have gone one of two ways it
could have been easier to break up with
him mm-hmm
or it would have been easier to work
through things with him because it
wouldn't have been so embarrassing okay
to be like me and my fiance are not
engaged anymore you know that's right I
think that that that once you get
engaged I think everything becomes 50
times more important and the stakes get
higher because it's like that thing
you're doing that annoys me is forever
now yes and there's a little bit of like
but I'm your wife you can't disrespect
you know everything to me took on such a
such higher stakes you know little
things became big things yeah and then
there's also this like but there's a
ring on your finger why would I ever do
that do you know there's an also it's
like you also
less ground to stand on right cuz
they're like I spent this money on you I
would I yeah well you can have done that
and still be rude yeah yes also you're
getting sloppy yes I feel like yeah this
was just gonna make everything Eve even
forever
it's the scorecard starts every morning
yes oh my god not it's you don't you're
not out of jail free
this isn't like immunity I completely
agree with that I think there was I
think they get comfortable yeah yeah you
guys they go I put a ring on it yeah
you're here yeah you put it on Instagram
you're not gonna untag me block me and
delete those so I solved your major
problem yeah I made you desirable and
yeah pathetic yeah
I made you like a bull quite frankly I
just helped you get a couple brand deals
now you owe me yeah I have filmed so
many videos of you in the pool who what
got the most likes on your Instagram
which was yeah which one no with your
engagement ring was it the selfie or was
over together yeah and I think man
that's so accurate it's like I need a
minute yeah I think so did you feel an
immediate shift I think so I think there
were things that I thought we had worked
through that then came back and got WAY
worse mm-hmm after we were engaged which
hurt even more than the first time and
the first time I was like this would be
a reason I would break up with you in
the future if we don't get a handle on
this right and then when it happened
later you know much like the impending
second wave of coronavirus it was even
more devastating because I we let this
get even worse this happened again and
now I feel stupid
yeah but for me it was like I was like
why would you do this we're engaged and
I'm sure on their end that you still
have the same neurology you had two
months exact how was your childhood
still the same right weren't you went to
a jewelry store right yes
didn't that change the way your
hippocampus is can
your frontal lobe I night decay jeweler
is in pain Julis a surgeon
didn't you get a lobotomy and charrids
didn't sales beat that out of him
what who would put in this much effort
hate to disappoint me you didn't go to
Zales and then automatically unfollow
all the porn stars right isn't that what
the story does I wish that's all it was
it just smells rinks yeah I I think I
think they get comfortable because they
go you're not going anywhere I lock this
down and all your friends are telling
you how great I am and how lucky you are
and you're telling me how great I am and
how lucky you are to have me and quite
frankly I believe it now yeah and you're
not going to find out about me doing
this thing and when you do find out I'm
gonna make you feel crazy yeah for
overreacting to it and yeah I I think I
also think how old is he he was 2 years
old maybe this is I think he's two years
older I don't know you know my my - my
my two most successful relationships
were with people you know 8 to 10 years
older than me yeah yeah yeah so you know
but also I was very I didn't get engaged
cuz I was unhappy like I was very happy
with that person and of course for like
eight eight nine months amazing so good
and thought like I was like this is what
I needed somebody who's not a comedian
but sort of comedy adjacent and can work
from home yeah and travel with me
sometimes and is very like even keel and
you know just really what was that on
your clipboard yeah it was on my list
that I wrote for my pass and that I once
works from home that good family check
good church-going boy check loves dogs
well I mean I don't want you to feel too
much responsibility as a successful
female comedian but I mean I went to
lunch with a girlfriend of mine after I
called off my engagement where I'm just
like I don't know if we can have
everything I'm like like I really I'm
like I'm so glad like Whitney's engaged
and happy because that makes me feel
better and she goes I think Whitney
called off her engagement I was like are
you
I like what's in the bathroom was just
like dry heaving Oh like it's not we
can't have him we can't have both
I have to choose because they're dry
cough no I was I was wet I'm so good wet
everywhere you guys everywhere so
dryness and my body because I think once
you get engaged the Machine sets off the
family start email and you get on a
chain you get the website you get there
like people start kicking in I've got
the ring you're using your grandma's
ring we're sending the lace like it
becomes this huge operation that you
become a really small part of yeah you
know the pressure the expectations
everyone starts inviting the family
friends and on tanana's gonna die soon
so we need to do it near where she is
and that by this type just becomes so
much bigger than you yeah and that was
disorienting to me did you buy a dress
no no did you it is in Irvine California
and I have not had time to pick it up
and now I can't because it's a
non-essential business that emailed me
today they've left me so many voicemails
where they're like hey so we should
probably get you fitted for this dress
cuz I ordered it because it's not like a
bitch did you not watch my special into
what took like eight months for them to
get make it or whatever so I ordered it
while we were engaged and it was the
first time I went to look at wedding
dresses I won with my best friend and I
found like my dream wedding dress and I
was like God and I was like great and
then cut to like a month later I'm like
giving the ring back and I'm just like
I'm like mmm
there were so many reasons that I wanted
to just push through it yes I had told
all my family I bought a dress I mean
that's half the women I know they're
like I bought a dress what was I gonna
do return I might as well just marry
this guy thank God I didn't spend a lot
of money like I spent I I was never
gonna spy a super expensive wedding
dress cuz like why would you do that
you're gonna wear it once but I have a
friend who bought a wedding dress that
it didn't go through the wedding
like it's a credit card like it didn't
go purple it was no one's fault
how that happened um and she dyed it
black and she wears it it's like a
cocktail dress it's actually well I was
upset that it did not come in time for
me to take promotional photos in it for
my special it you know it came in a
little later than that and then by the
time it came in I didn't want to go get
it it's a bit of a drive yeah yeah and
then I have to get it fitted and I just
couldn't I couldn't walk in there and be
like can I just get it in a trash bag I
was like I was like I'm gonna go in
there and just have them like fit me I
guess and when they're like so May 30th
I'm gonna go yeah like I I wasn't sure
how to handle it what does it look like
I mean I'll show you a picture I mean he
is so curious it's and it should be
point we both have each other
I mean let's do it please I feel like we
take really good care of don't you think
so very similar do I still have an album
label dress in my phone yes I do
I probably 200 it's pretty right god
it's gorgeous
no and your badonkadonk but is on phone
yeah full display
did you cuz it's interesting because you
I think really learn a lot about who you
are when you try on wedding dresses
whether or not you're engaged or not I'd
suggest everybody do it the salespeople
love it
I love when you come in not engaged and
just try it come on with your filthy
body it was just so weird cuz I when I
went and tried wedding dresses on it was
just so odd what I thought I would like
we all have this image of you know the
wedding dress you'd wear I picture just
like really big and just Disney or
whatever I got it I was like no I think
I'm a straight down mermaid person well
I have a picture of the other one you're
on the long sleeve lady's purse I was a
long sleeve lace person would have
called that with you I was gonna say
strap I was gonna say strapless never in
front of my grandparents no what is this
a horror themed wedding I
never have cleavage in front of my
grandparents well you can get him you
know does I mean what did you just
picture when I said I don't know well
this is this was the other one that I
was looking at which was very very
different and very cleavagey this one is
I'm trying to show this one is a little
Oksana Baiul that one's a little like a
little let's skip the daddy-daughter
dance yeah but it looks so good on me
but your fiance would have been able to
motorboat you at any point it was a
great dress and they don't read in the
wedding it was also like off the rack
the perfect size so flattering so that
was almost it and then I would old
Russian is it yeah yeah bad one
is there no the good Russia you know
like The Dictator
like Americans they had show the
Americans like like Keri Russell like
this dress could ruin a democracy that's
what I'm saying it's interesting and
these are off-white you're an off-white
person you had a full white person
either yeah not a full white person gosh
it's so weird were you a veil person
they do the thing in the store were they
what what did they say on say yes to the
dress were they Jack you up that's how
they say it on say yes to the dress
where they give you a fake bouquet and a
veil and they take pictures of you in
the right light and you could kind of
decide I definitely was not gonna be a
veil person I do have a oh I do have a
wedding venue album yeah but these are
dresses that I'm not in that I didn't
try on but you took pictures of the
dress no there were like screen grabs
from Instagram oh that's really pretty
I had a cape that I I was gonna wear you
were gonna wear a cake I mean I don't
know ice cream grabbed this yeah I
wanted to look like I mean super here I
can picture the wedding shots of you in
a large field on a huge estate walking
your three dogs with with a gauzy cape
behind you I was full cape once I saw
that you could get a wedding cape that
was it I also was thinking about doing a
suit like remember when Celine Dion war
suit backwards
so great I was like I could do that but
I don't know that's probably not it's
gonna get as many likes and instead the
the hot white suit that's you could do
that for a special you know what I mean
maybe I don't think so i think that
people and their specials should dress
simply classic timeless you're very good
at this
oh thank you're special we'll hold up
very well thank you I hope so
you know that was the I loved the
Canadian tuxedo you went with oh gosh
yeah do you regret it you know I don't I
don't I just I I always panic in a
special and I always I look I'm a 90s
bitch and that's just who I am and I
always look 90s and that's just it I
thought you like 90s and your other
specials yes no I didn't think so
really you had like a you had like a
blazer on and yeah the the HBO special I
was wearing I looked like Amelie I look
like Emily's aunt I looked like a French
mime you looked very chic okay thank you
I got that was like a suit that was a
suit with like a camisole underneath yes
cuz I was like I'm gonna be a feminine
I'm gonna try to not neuter myself this
was back when there was such a thing as
gender and this was back when I used to
classify it and so yeah and then I wore
heels that's the first time I wear heels
in a special and that was a Mustang you
know I was gonna ask you about the
stupid person dumb lady
I mean you pulled it off thank you
that's very there was no point where I
was like who's she struggling in me to
roll her ankle on her closer so that was
a less physical special as I recall and
I remember thinking for that special
maybe I shouldn't be so manic like I
remember looking back and just saying
sometimes I'm just like a little manic
on stage and it helped me wearing a
little kitten heel help me just kind of
hold my power a little bit and be a
little more still right those were not
kitten heels though those were
intentional that's true you know what a
kitten heel it's yours were like the
height of an actual kitten standing on
its hind legs they they were they were
real here ya know they were a couple
inches which made me think it's so funny
because I
you probably have people tell you like
you seems so much older than you are not
your face not because of your face my
soul my insides but I'm my gut source or
ancient I got a lot of that too I don't
get it anymore I now get like you need
to grow up I age backwards I'm like
mentally Benjamin Button but I'm so
curious if there are things that you
haven't heard of like references that I
know owe him here 26 yes Lisa Loeb I've
heard I've heard I couldn't tell you
what Lisa Loeb looks like or what she
does but I've heard Lisa Lowe I love
this shit so much
nothing Lisa Loeb you say how's your
singer oh that's Lisa Loeb why not it's
on how don't listen hard guy reruns full
house reality bites oh really
yeah she was I do I do love that movie
but you didn't watch MTV when MTV had
music videos no reality TV not really
I've never really watched reality TV
though do you know her Jordan Catalano
is yes I do know who Jordan Catalano is
oh yeah yeah from my so-called glass
yeah yeah oh so what can you watch all
days
yes I think I I don't remember why I
watched that it was probably on some
list that I was like oh I should look
that up it wasn't easy to find that
hello when I watched it oh that's
interesting
but I had that you're young you probably
ripped it off Napster I probably did I
watched the office in very low quality
yeah I do you know the crash test
dummies this is a deep cut do I know
what a crash test dummies like the
commercials were in cars there's a band
called crash test dummy oh I didn't know
that mmm this is really bad mm-hmm
remember once there was a girl who got
into an accident and wouldn't come to
school and when this is the music you
guys have you heard like ariana grande
it's pretty upbeat places someone gotten
an axe I can't believe it
didn't come to school we're over here
like thank you next my life's gonna be
better I can't believe that we listen to
shit like this of course you don't know
it once there was a girl who what was it
couldn't change with the girls in the
change room do you guys remember does no
no one's in here don't worry about
Carrie okay yeah I can't believe hold on
I have to pull it up so you don't think
I'm just making this up
you
was it your kids noise noise you listen
to now look at my butt look at my butt
we had real music what song is that look
at my butt
I don't know that that's that's the
oldest thing you've ever said by the way
not like your music now look at my butt
look at my butt even my grandpa what I
said ass call me aunt Whitney from now
on
do you remember Sinead O'Connor yes
didn't she get in trouble on SNL oh my
gosh that's your reference point yeah I
think that's the shaved head yeah she
was a singer in my day right that's all
I know I couldn't sing you one song can
you I can oh I'm sure I'm sure you guys
know me too
I'm sure you guys are just sitting there
waiting for me to do it how did it go
mama what was it mom Oh since you've
been gone
no I'm see I know that one
Sinead O'Connor nothing compares oh she
sounds exactly like that as well
oh nothing compares the good news is
better dead mom you have a very
promising internet career post pandemic
when we can't perform for people anymore
life you're gonna be great on YouTube
doing impressions of singers I mean this
pandemic has been great for my career I
mean is that I'm in a pivot and a pivot
heart Logan Paul I'm coming for you come
for your money I'm coming for your
Ferraris coming for your Tigers coming
for all of it can you name the singers
of TLC what TLC do you remember TLC I'm
more of an HGTV I again I love say yes
to the dress
what not to wear but deal see you've
heard the band I've heard the band yeah
but you don't know what TL & C starts no
dancing where T is T Boz L is left died
and C is chilly Pelle are these names
yeah oh the fingers oh yeah all right
I'm like this is so fascinating to me
Judy what did you watch going up
I mean like Lizzie McGuire I'm really
young man that's so sweet it was
genuinely very sad when Hilary Duff is
like we're not making what's right there
they were moving for because they
wouldn't let her make it like edgy right
yeah mm-hmm
I mean she's also the best she's I mean
you probably have you met her hmm is she
the best the best person oh I know the
nicest kindest love like just like it's
weird because I think that I've had my
heart broken by so many people like
meeting heroes meeting famous people
same names oh honey let's see how this
how this quarantine goes oh I'm happy to
burn bridges if there's the bridges
aren't leading anywhere yeah when this
business collapses I will name all the
name I'm so excited when I become a
YouTube star this is the first time I've
wanted it to get worse for now I need to
kiss everybody's ass even though I hate
them oh that's great she's so she's like
a delight like rescues dogs like makes
her own almond milk oh I know he's also
has not aged at all 12 day she looks
exactly the same she's maybe the most
beautiful person I've ever seen
yeah no practice it's so nice when
people are like nicer than you expect
them to be yeah I know it's so it's so
funny because you don't get points for
that that's my whole thing when
someone's like she's so nice it's like
okay you don't get points for that
Ohio's being but we are at this point
where we kind of have to when someone's
not an asshole we're look thank you so
much for not throwing something at me I
know like when did our bar gets so low I
know just I mean there's there's
different levels to it there's like
coffee we're so nice it's like really
why what were they like no they just
like they sat down and they talked to me
and they look me in the eye and I'm like
I was human yeah yeah I was doing they
said thank you yeah that's not the same
thing I'll use you as an example you can
sit here and feel awkward about this so
the first time I met you was at the DC
improv which I'm praying for every day I
love them so much okay
DC improv about I get what was this year
when did you film your special March so
year ago what's only a year ago a year
ago and I was headlining that weekend
you were filming your special in DC
yeah and the manager Allison asked me
the first day on Thursday at Radio she
goes Whitney wants to come in and do a
10-minute guest spot and I was like do
you still want me to do the show and she
was like no I'm asking you if you're
okay with Whitney doing a guest spot and
I was like Whitney can do the whole
weekend
like what are you talking about like
she's like no it's just you know you're
the headliner and like she's filming her
special she wants to just work on like a
joke and I said yeah of course that's
fine you came in you first off acted
like we had met before we had not which
was very nice of you this is like Sona I
was like here's what I'll say I think I
had I'd first seen you right do you know
what I mean and I knew of you but that's
what a nice famous person does they go
hey how are you like you've met before
it's absolutely the nicest thing to do
because you don't know maybe we did meet
once at the Comedy Store and you can't
remember we I'm telling you we hadn't
cuz I would have remembered but I just
thought it was nice that you came in
like we're both comics worried and I I
definitely didn't forget how no this is
ridiculous how could you even ask me
that
so you came in you're like we're just
you treated me like we were the same and
I'm like we're not you could have done
the show you think I profusely for a
guest spot I was looking at your butt
the entire time I was completely
objectifying you thanked me profusely
for a ten-minute guest spot did not run
the light by a second gave me a
shout-out on your Instagram and then
sent flowers to my hotel room the next
day so either you were the nicest person
ever you have an amazing assistant and I
left that weekend going Whitney Cummings
is the classiest person in show business
I think like who does that so now that
is Remini guess what my first time ever
headlining this was wasn't the first
time your headline was at the Addison
improv a very famous comedian showed up
asked to do a ten minute guess spot I
said sure and he did 45 minutes that's
insane us oh my gosh Carlos Mencia
anyway orig
[Laughter]
you guys know in this podcast I don't
lie to you I wouldn't I shan't
I shall not I only work with sponsors
that I truly like and I'm gonna prove
this to you this is I'm about to talk
about Brooklyn and this is a friend of
mine Tuesday at 9:26 p.m. hey I feel
like you'd be the person to answer this
question do you know what the nicest
sheets to get are like the brand this is
a text from Nasim pedrad I'm showing it
to you I write back this is real
I wrote this back this is before I ever
read this ad responding I wrote verbatim
only ones I like Brooklyn in supersoft
comma buttery didn't get paid to text
that to her no I didn't this these are
my side conversations when I'm not
rolling okay
I love this company Brooklyn and was the
first direct-to-consumer betting company
no one wants to go in a store right now
not in this climate
Brooklyn was very ahead of the curve
which we are all desperately trying to
flatten they work directly with
manufacturers directly with consumers no
middlemen so you're getting the luxury
products without all that markup variety
of sheets tons of colors patterns mine
are white well I have three dogs so
they're kind of yellowish no but I think
they were white whatever but yeah this
is the only betting I use that's all
that's all I can tell you I have
purchased this product on my own
Brooklyn and sheets they are the perfect
place to start making your mornings
great or now that we're in a pandemic
your full days since we just spend all
day in bed now Brooklyn it is so
confident in their product that all
their been in bettin C bent it I miss
Benton calling bedding Benton oh this is
a really telling ad read their bedding
comes with a life time warranty get 10%
off your first order and free shipping
when you use the promo code Whitney
that's me only at Brooklyn and calm BR
oh okay li n en comm promo code Whitney
get 10% off your first order and free
shipping when you use promo code Whitney
only at Brooke linen calm BR oh okay
Elle
any n.com promo code whitney brooklyn
and everything you need to live your
most comfortable life women's razors
cost up to 15% more than men's
well unbelievable it's called the pink
tax look it up google it folks
the idea that women should have to pay
more for the same product is how trudges
not only is it out prejudice it also
guys razors are so much more complicated
still cheaper than ours okay this is why
billy was invented they deliver premium
razors directly to you for half the
price of what you find in the store so
you're not gonna get hoodwinked anymore
billy's putting a stop to the
skullduggery of the razor business and
you know what they sent me some shaved
my legs eyes closed didn't even cut my
knee that's a big deal it takes a lot to
get me to shave took a pandemic but i
did it and this is the first razor i've
ever used that doesn't make me look like
I've been attacked by a shark and is
affordable nine dollars you can get four
refill blades every one two or three
months based on how often you shave
which in this time might not be very
much and good for you
each razor cartridge includes five
american-made blades don't worry they
don't have that Wuhan on them encased in
aloe soap for the smoothest shave that's
gentle on your sensitive skin they also
have more space between each blade to
allow the shave cream soap and hair to
pass on by that's probably why I wasn't
hemorrhaging afterward it's good to know
allure chose them is their best beauty
winner nylon also they're winning all
the awards love it get free shipping
always skip adjust to cancel your
subscription any time it's not like the
stupid gym you can get out if you want
to but you won't want to express a
little love for our show go to my Billy
comm slash Whitney for 10% off your
razor it's a small way you can support
us while also getting the best razor of
your life half the price plus shipping
is always free limited time special
offer so go now
get 10% off your razor at my Billy
dot-com and your body's gonna
look like a porpoise in no time I cannot
think of one famous comedian who I would
expect to be that trepidatious about it
I really cannot like to me it just seems
like such a no-brainer yeah that
somebody who was filming a special that
weekend yeah and his famous would not be
like is this cool of course it is I know
like I just I just I don't know I mean
and maybe this is why I like you so much
in vibrate with you I just don't have
that entitlement thing I think it I feel
like this is you know I can't I do us
this is your show you know oh I still
won't park in the paid regular a lot of
the Comedy Store because I feel weird
making friends of mine park my car by
the way good like good that is like the
healthy reaction like I think that a lot
of people that have big egos I get it I
get but I think the best comedians are
the ones that for their entire career
are like is this okay is this cool
because you're staying in touch with
reality your empathic your sensitive
those are the best comedians yeah the
ones that are like who me shucks like
those are the ones that I think are the
best writers the best performers and
have the biggest careers yeah someone
that comes in and this isn't you but the
people who come in that they do one you
know set on TV and they're like I
fucking killed who says that oh my god
you're not fun there's no way you're
funny the best comedians come offstage
and like how was that was that okay
beating themselves up having panic
attacks totally spiraling could have
done that better
I remember my um I want to say this mice
and I did like my second special nervous
it was an HBO special so is my third
special and they were like you know what
we should do this was a time when
everyone was doing like opens and like
little skits and fro yeah mirror which I
don't you know I just like I just like
to kind of get to it and I did open my
special with an elaborate
man-on-the-street bit yeah where I
pretended like nobody knew that's not it
I was performing at the venue but it's
fine that's not like I'm joking I didn't
do that
I mean that it depends on how its
executed right a lot of people are gonna
get mad at me about this I know I think
most people say that now most people are
like joke let's not do any skits I
haven't seen
any I mean we had like 20 seconds of me
backstage with music over it and yeah
mine and I was like yeah yeah because
you see so many like famous comedians
now who just come out to silence and
you're like that's pretty cool but you
also have people who are like losing
their shit yeah I mean we people were
there to see me and it was very nice but
it wasn't like you know like Marc Maron
walking out to a smaller room of people
and they're just like please welcome
Marc Maron you're like this is the
coolest shit I'm like we need to kind of
build me up a little bit because people
are most people are gonna watch this
going all right I'm like no this make me
look cool for like 20 seconds I think
though it's also we're at this place
where it's like there are a lot of
people so I'm obsessing over this like I
haven't washed my hair in so long it
looks good and I have this like weird
I look like Theo von I have this weird
chunk of like dreadlock happening I look
like Jason full Jason Momoa but yeah
what is that's really annoying me um I I
think though that there's so many super
famous comedians that we all think are
famous that no one knows about and they
seen for the first time i Netflix right
next to your special yours famous to
some what you know ii mean it's like
yeah i think we're in this place now
where people are someone either has
never heard of you or knows what you had
for breakfast right there's no
in-between
someone's famous if you follow them so
if somebody follows you you're the most
famous person in their life I mean it's
there the days of everyone having the
same celebrities or is just over yeah
you know what you're probably right
I mean that's my brand probably right I
make money don't be the new tour when
you're like I'm not sure if it's if it's
ethically right for me to be doing live
shows and haters only the right decision
and you'll probably live probably okay
but no true pointed like you know so
they were like let's film you coming
offstage let's have some
behind-the-scenes this is like right
when it was like we need social media
content and we had to film ourselves
doing everything all the time and I was
like okay sure like if you guys want to
film me coming upstage go for it I come
upstage like shows it's like second show
Saturday so it's like
everyone's gonna you know Energy's great
I come off it's the best version of what
I'm gonna do I've been doing it for a
year it's your special can't go better
than this
yeah I've never been more rehearsed or
prepared for this couldn't gone better i
go offstage that we play the footage
back like in post and editing like I
look devastated I look heartbroken I
look like I'm grieving I I'm not I'm not
the person who comes up stages like yeah
fucking nailed it like I'm not that
person I come off stage and I'm like ah
shit I did that out of order like I
should have done this better like what
was that like I yeah like melancholy
yeah I couldn't use the footage yeah it
was sad shoot me going on stage nigga
get shoot me like yeah you know there's
a camera there I'll fake it
yeah but I'm not I'm not that person at
all you got to pretend to believe in
yourself before you go onstage and then
once you're off you're like I just
tricked all those people what a great
way to say it I got to pretend to
believe in myself yeah I feel the same
way when I get offstage I feel like just
like okay like everyone get away from me
no it's a job you know it is a job
that's that's why I like you so much as
you treat it like a job and you like
make it okay to not be treating it like
a party not enjoy you are not that fun
Whitney and I really love that about you
because I'm not fun I'm glad I've made
it okay for you to be miserable either
you are hot and efficient and successful
and I really enjoy it I think it's very
inspiring and that's who I look to okay
I when I was on tour with uh with Burt I
was like when I was younger I would
feature for him and I was so impressed
with who he was and how he operates on
the out and how he just brings everyone
into his ya world and I was also like I
will never never could never do it I
look on the bus there's all this code
like one of these people on the bus
what's what are you what is are we
washing our hands or whose sleeve do we
go to sing at the same time yeah I need
in order to socialize for two hours I
need about five days yes to like
rev up yeah Oh after this pandemic I
genuinely think I might be an extrovert
afterward I feel like after this I'm
gonna be like oh I get why people wanna
yeah a talking line at the grocery store
this makes sense to me sending your dog
just farted and my dog just farted I
think so yeah no he's been so long he's
been farting a lot I also think he said
daughter no no you're done okay no just
what I'm six feet away from you but I'm
trying to waft afire comfort is that
your excuse cuz you think I'm giving you
a Corona
oh wait a second we actually had an
interesting conversation downstairs of
when you go outside now and you go near
someone there's this unanimous decision
this very consensual almost
choreographed leaned away from each
other
mm-hmm and I appreciate that that's us
all doing what we're supposed to be
doing good straight-a students but
there's a are we saying is the subtext I
might have this or is it you look like
you have this I think it's case by case
I think if I see someone coming towards
me and they look very well-groomed and
they're already leaning I trust them
love that person and I go this is on me
I'm I'm the trash fire walking for you
and I will go into the gutter you can
keep the sidewalk but if they you're the
clown and yes this is how you tell if
you're walking towards me on the
sidewalk and I go into the street it
means I respect you yeah if I go onto
someone's lawn to avoid you that means I
think I'm better than you I remember
there's this guy once when I was like in
my twenties like a friend of mine that
like hooked up with a lot of girls and I
was like I hope you're using protection
right and he's like here's the key to
using a condom if you hook up with a
girl and she insists on using a condom
you don't need to use one because that
means she uses it all the time I can't
believe we're friends with any men but
that works it's to this example if
someone's super anal I'm like okay
you're good right yeah that was us
texting each other this morning
are you comfortable doing this if you're
not comfortable then that makes me more
comfortable we cancelled this they say
sighs yeah are you trying to cancel me
maybe like oh we're good
I have legitimately been listening to
the beginnings of people's podcasts
where they talk about how they're doing
yelling can I go do their podcast
have they been staying inside yeah yeah
yeah because I just you don't know how
you don't like you know it's are you you
you've done a couple of your podcast
remotely mm-hmm
so tell me about your podcast it's
called self helpless it's called self
helpless I do it with Kelsey Cook and
Delaney Fisher Kelsey is also a touring
comic and Delaney used to do stand-up
that's how we all met and now she owns
her own business and works from home I'm
so fascinated when I see younger female
comics being friends oh yeah that's know
is a new fun thing oh yeah because
there's more of us or do you think it's
gotten less competitive that's a great
question which by the way I do not judge
competitive female comics hot take is
that a lot of them yes
can be nasty and and but I do think my
generation and up we had to be like that
to navigate this do you know what I mean
yeah so we get grandfathered in we get
to be a little prickly right okay we're
allowed to being competitive because I
think that chicken-and-egg that's the
only way you had to be like really alpha
and really fierce and really competitive
in order to say I want to go do that at
2:00 in the morning every night with a
bunch of drunk bros yes you know what I
mean so I I give I give them a pass
whenever people complain about how mean
female comics out other female comics
I'm like there used to be one slot on it
yes a competitive cap because it was a
competition
yeah very recently I think there's a
nice way to acknowledge the competition
though yeah I think I haven't had
anybody be like a bitch to me like I
haven't had any of that belief but I
think any time that I have felt that
yeah between me and another person we
both acknowledged it yeah I'm like okay
well they do not give many spots to this
person so if anybody's gonna get it it's
gonna be one of
like that kind of thing like this is
just good game yeah I mean I did last
comic standing five six years ago yeah
and I remember being in a van with
esther povitsky and we were like in the
top 20 yeah and we were in the van going
well we're both its young white girls so
it'll be one of us that goes to top ten
and I think by that point we were so
tired of the reality show aspect really
I hope it's you I hope it's like I have
a good joke for you I have a good closer
what you say you take mine use your
minds combine the best of both yeah no I
think also like you know I think that
there's a little bit of a confusion and
maybe it's just the scarcity complex
thing like you know and I try to save as
much as I can it's like it doesn't help
female comics if other female comics
fail or aren't funny yes you know so
there is a little bit and maybe it's
just other people pitting women against
each other you know like when I walk
through an airport someone will come up
to me and be like oh my god I love you
and then it'll just list the other
female comics they don't think are funny
right and I hate female camels like so
and so so about you yeah and this wasn't
that funny you're like I know they're my
friend you're kind of just trashing my
friends but I see what you're doing um
but I I think people to understand like
if a female comic isn't funny then when
our specials come up and people don't
know who we are
they're gonna go uh that didn't work out
last time like yeah the morphine won't
comment that are funny the more everyone
succeeds yeah you know what I mean so
it's like it's just like sort of a weird
thing to be competitive about it it's
just like mathematically wrong yeah
people will give my special a chance not
knowing who I am
yeah because they watched you or like
Joe if you like this also watch this
yeah yeah everybody helps everybody you
know and it's just it's it's it's so
interesting to me and I never know if
it's sort of the kind of personality
that would sign up to do such a savage
job it's just gonna have to be a savage
person or what it is exactly yeah I mean
I feel like being like a white guy in
your 30s right now the competition isn't
that's like the hardest thing I mean it
was funny I was sitting I was at the
improv with Sarah Silverman this must
have been like I don't know like six
months ago back when we were allowed to
go outside
and we were watching some guy I don't
know who was it was like I don't think I
knew him but he was on stage you're just
like a white guy talking about his
family or something and Sarah looked at
me and she was just like this is
actually really funny like when it's not
all of them like I actually really enjoy
that like it's really it's refreshing to
hear this point of view yeah it's not
the only point of view yeah you know
yeah that's the idea is to make
everybody's point of view refreshing
yeah because everybody's getting a
minute yeah yeah it's been interesting
do you find that guys you know I'll just
say that I do that sometimes guys will
come up to me and the big look my
girlfriend loves you I don't know you
but my girlfriend thinks you're
hilarious can we get a picture I'm like
you're allowed to think a girl's funny
yeah you can like me right you don't
have to say it's your girlfriend yeah do
you see do you think you would get
mostly men or women when you look out
kai I got a guy at where was I I think
it was at the Brea improv this was like
a year ago maybe or maybe a little less
and a guy came up to me with his
girlfriend he goes look I hate female
comedians like here we go yes he made me
come and he takes out a small bottle of
fireball and he goes I brought this to
get drunk because I thought you were
gonna suck and I'm like honey goes you
were great I didn't even open it like I
don't know how to feel because on the
one foot ball thank you is I win would
you like a photo yes first also fuck you
a little also tag me yeah I'll take what
I can get
Wow I know to admit something like that
is pretty nuts
I know he wants points for that oh so
any point he thinks you're gonna go like
we got one everybody my god yeah yes yes
I'm gonna ring a bell like he like we
got a donation were so many
opportunities for him to turn around and
not do that mm-hmm
so many times I want to talk about your
progress cuz it's about stuff help
mostly right it is
self-help yeah I want to see if there's
anything I can help you with oh my gosh
there's so much he could help me with
I'm sure I was 26 I mean I was
unconscious really you seemed very clear
yeah thank you so much I think I'll for
where honestly and this is maybe a
little morbid but my mom died when she
was 34 I laugh at sad things okay so you
can't say sad things to me because I
start laughing that's totally fine and
it's people laughing at me no but it's
good it's good it's like I might have to
go for a walk
oh no really yeah like sad things make
me laugh like uncontrollably oh I'm
sorry it's like an emotional dyslexia
can I not get real no I wasn't ready I
was kidding I was alive oh thank god oh
thank god oh my god you're just about a
lighted dream once of my mom died at 34
and I've AM cheated with your mom is
that the story okay sorry I think I just
have always expected and maybe you I
don't know this might not be a dead
parent thing this could just be some a
workaholic things but I've always felt
like I'm running out of time yeah you're
having all of your emotional work
completely undone oh no you are running
out right well I feel like I know you
don't work hard enough thank you oh my
god I just start three more podcasts I I
have always felt like I'm gonna be dead
at 34 and I felt like weights why I've
been lucky in this business where I'm
like wow I do work hard and I try to I'm
yeah deserve what I get but I also every
time I get something like I kid you not
Whitney when this pandemic hit uh-huh is
that a week after my special came out I
was like I knew it I knew it I knew
something that I knew was going too well
mm-hmm and I knew something meanwhile so
many more people are watching your
special event oh I hate getting that
feedback to where people are just like
hey everyone's watching Netflix right
now I'm like I think everyone was
watching Netflix just slower are you
saying it took a pandemic to get people
to watch my
what you're saying that seemed I don't
know he ran out of things to watch yeah
that sounds like something well he's not
gonna cheat on you well II can't but
yeah I think I've just always felt like
I don't have enough time to be
unconscious like I never felt like I
could party
yeah or hang out yeah drink or anything
yeah I was like I don't have time to
have my life fall apart and then put
myself back together I have to be
together because I'm going to be dead
very soon yeah cuz your mom died fuck
yeah it's Larry
oh it's look my dad is dead which is
also so funny now laughing okay now let
me it's it's when other people tell me
something horrible I can't handle I've
always laughed at things that are
horrific it's just my emotional dyslexia
that's you know I think it's helped me
coping mechanism prepared okay your mom
passed when she was 34 huh you should be
sorry
how could you come in here and ambush me
bad news when you know my brain is
broken so how old were you I was eight
okay okay yeah yeah so then I went
through puberty a year later and it
became abundantly clear that I was not
going to get hot after this tragedy and
I'm you're very hot this is recent this
is I'm not even that hot like I think
I'm cute but this is like the last few
years like I I was not like your face
turned I I don't think I was even in the
neighborhood of hot until like three
years ago really yeah I think you're
very hot and that's the consensus you
I'm not the consensus I feel like if you
the consensus she's like a vixen really
like a hot vixen you you haven't spoken
anyone in 13 I don't consensus voices
you my dog just think so look I'm in a
lot of text change with a lot of
comedians and if you don't think we
brought up your but you are sorely
mistaken yeah no I've heard if you think
the me to movement made it to comedy you
are wrong
laughing I've heard I've sweetheart I
developed really early
as a kid like I started wearing a sports
bra when I was in third grade
and so people were commenting on like my
boobs and my ass yeah or they should
have been probably and I wasn't but my
face wasn't like killing it so I just
really got a baby I think I might have
been no I I was just like I was this
height in fifth grade like I was maybe
an inch shorter like I just looked 15
when I was 10 and so for me I didn't
want any very bottom yeah and I didn't
want anyone looking at my body
mm-hmm in that way because I didn't feel
ready for it and you were a friend
because you were because I wasn't thank
you if I didn't feel ready I just didn't
feel ready you weren't ready to be sex
traffic you were shy it was a child but
I just didn't uh I didn't want anybody
looking at me that way but then you
still want to be pretty but then you
don't when people comment on specific
parts of your body you start to feel
like they're like chopping you up yes
it's going this bits good and you're
like yeah I did morning mica night into
the mitt yeah well it's also like I'm
thinking about what you said I was like
god it's so weird that she felt the need
to be pretty at a young age I'm like oh
no we have pageants we have children in
tanning beds yeah wearing wet and wild
lip gloss like we do sexualize actual
children yeah and you spend so much time
trying to be pretty and then you get
into comedy yeah and you go oh I have to
not be pretty to be good at this and for
me when I found comedy I was like cool I
don't have to be pretty yeah I can stop
trying to be pretty and just focus on
being funny hmm and then once people
started making comments like oh you're
just you're not funny you're just pretty
like that which I don't get a ton of
that but sometimes I did I was like mad
where I was like I would get more mad at
myself I got mad at myself a month ago
doing the Tonight Show where I was like
you dumb bitch trying to look good when
you're just supposed to be funny like
you it I was so mad because to me it was
like I still feel like sometimes
you can be both but your first priority
has to be funny and so I think for me
becoming a comedian was like a relief of
like I found it's like when you were a
kid and they go you know you're not that
pretty but you have a great personality
and I got something yeah and you meet
someone with a great personality who's
also very symmetrical and you're like
some people just get fucking everything
it doesn't seem at all so like once I go
they have depression thank God
yeah yeah and then once I started doing
stand-up I was like cool I'm just gonna
be funny I don't need to
I will make up for my looks this way
mm-hmm by being really and then your
genetics kicked in and you got hot
you're very like jacking up hot thank
you so much that is what works best on
me you're very um it's not who is it
like not Betty Page who's it's so you've
got very like 50s pinup hot oh thank you
I think of other Betty Betty Davis
I don't know see I'm not that old Betty
Betty Page is like Betty porn was a
pin-up girl it's actually fascinating to
me I'm I'm obsessed with women that were
sex symbols that knew they shouldn't be
photographed after a certain time and
just kind of disappeared uh-huh so Betty
Page also Hedy Lamarr did the same thing
Betty Page at like 35 moved to Florida
and doesn't allow any photos to be taken
of her cuz she's like I wanted to be
remembered that way is she still alive
don't know that's that's I mean that's a
perfect example of how well she did that
we're like is she still alive right
honey that we don't know deceased died
in 2008 but the last pictures of her
when to when she was like 35 I think I
like I've expired and never let any
photos be taken of her I think I watched
a movie about her mm-hmm and I genuinely
thought she died young that was her plan
she wanted to be remembered that way
isn't that URI and weird she knew she's
like I know my value and I want to be
immortalized this way that makes me so
sad as a woman and so impressed from a
branding perspective I'm like should I
just disappear now so ask me something
asked me something that you guys have
not figured out on your because I think
I was gonna come to your podcast at some
Pillai think so
and now I mean yeah
oh I wanted to ask you this how do you
suffer from imposter syndrome oh of
course
still yeah I mean because you seem very
self-aware but you also seem pretty
confident like we just talked about the
like oh I hate myself I didn't do that
right yeah that's like perfectionism and
workaholism yeah of course we all have
that but the imposter syndrome and I
don't deserve this and I'm not good
enough yeah
do you still struggle with I'm sorry
okay I don't have so I don't
I definitely don't hate myself like I
don't say that anymore even as a joke
that's one of the off-limits things for
me but like when I come off stage and
I'm like AHA what the fuck
like it's more like how did I do that I
could have done that better which is
true yes saying I could have done
something better is not low self-esteem
I don't like this thing we're now at if
self edification and self-improvement is
now self-flagellating it's not it's a
scientific fact that if I go on stage
and I come off I probably could have
done something a little bit better the
audience will never know the difference
it doesn't matter but I know I know
yeah do you know what I'm saying yeah
I'm the one that did this so I know that
I could have done better you guys don't
get to decide that I have low
self-esteem because I want this to be as
good as it can be like I refuse on that
I refuse for someone being wanting to be
excellent as like being pathologized as
a perfectionist yes you don't I mean as
long as you yourself have times that you
go
that was excellent that's right that's
right but if you never do that you're a
great agree agree agree
so impostor syndrome for me I I don't
think I don't deserve certain things I
actually think I deserve a lot more oh
my god teach me how to go that way I
have had a lot of things in this
business go sideways and like really
unfairly not happen because of people's
egos and bad behavior granted I made bad
decisions
I mean I didn't I didn't they weren't
bad at the time with my clipboard and on
paper I didn't trust my gut about
certain people that ended up being you
know megalomaniacs and narcissists and
that destroyed things so I had a lot of
things that I wanted to happen not
happen because I had the wrong team in
place you know so I think I deserved for
those things to happen III have reversed
imposter syndrome
the couple projects okay well I'm like
it's unfair that that that didn't happen
I mean look I but I'm also I'm gonna
tell us that program and step three is
everything is happening exactly as it
should and thank God those didn't happen
and I dodged a bullet in rejection it's
God's protection and all that you know
looking back it is the best thing that
happened I know that but I I still am
allowed to say I deserve that and I
didn't get it and life's not fair and
that's fine inter I definitely have I
think because we're magicians in a way
you know we sometimes go on stage and
you guys are gonna think we're having
the best time of our lives and we're
really sad inside or confused or you
might think that we you know are really
in the moment in present when sometimes
we're not and we're thinking about our
next joke or whatever I went onstage I
did two months of stand-up right after
my dad died and no one would have known
you know a lot of what we do is acting
so when I have a the imposter syndrome
of I tricked them sometimes that's true
you know so I have a little bit of
they're gonna find out that I'm a phony
there's a little bit of that because I
think sometimes we have to be because of
the circumstances I mean I was dreading
doing shows the week that everyone was
canceling cuz corona cuz I was like I'm
not to go to Detroit and I'll have to go
in there and I'm gonna have to pretend
I'm not scared yeah and I'm gonna have
to pretend that every time I hear a
coffee I don't hear it I'm gonna have to
barrel through these jokes I'm gonna
have to like lie about why I can't do a
meet and greet like I was like I'm gonna
have to be a complete phony and
sometimes we have to do that you know so
I think that I some I have to delineate
the difference between impostor syndrome
and like no I did kind of just pull one
over because I had to because we have to
perform we plan at six months in advance
and we don't know what's gonna happen
that morning and if my mom is sick and
something bad happens and I just heard
bad news I still have to go onstage and
not let anyone know but that's a
difference between this audience is
going to find out that I'm sad today and
every audience is gonna find out I
actually suck yeah yeah yeah I remember
when I first was touring I was opening
for this male comedian that was pretty
big at the time and his whole thing was
about being
married guy being a married guy and his
kids and his wife and the thing and uh
probably his annoying naggy wife cuz all
wives are annoying in a nightmare
you know dare they rear and raise your
children you proposed to them
I mean I don't like he went and bought
the ring why okay and he was broken up
they were they had been divorced for
like six months and every night before
he went on stage he'd put on his wedding
ring Oh brutal that is so brute yeah
that to me is when when I think when I'm
being false are not telling the truth
you know that's when I would feel like I
was just being fake or being phony but I
think that I think that that goes away
with time you know I think I definitely
felt it more in the beginning and I
don't feel it as much anymore because of
how much I've given up for this and how
hard I've worked
I don't really feel it anymore yeah you
know I feel it a little bit with like a
podcast because I don't know what I'm
doing like the place I feel impostor
syndrome is like with a podcast you know
stuff that I haven't been doing for a
really long time like I look at you know
someone like Rogan and people in Bobby
Lee and friends might've been doing
pockets for a long time and I'm like I
don't want you to think that I am like
think I'm you you know it's for that
yeah you know because I'm really big
into meritocracy we're so worried about
what other kind they don't give a shit
doesn't look good for you can I come in
your podcast and I'm like but I'm not
trying to steal your light they're like
yeah we don't think you are yeah fine
yeah I mean I don't know I think I think
comedians who are successful don't worry
about other people being successful
mm-hmm I think unsuccessful comedians
yeah talk a lot of shit yeah that's
correct and so if someone's talking shit
about you it's like they're talking shit
about everybody yeah that's right like
they're they're probably saying like and
they have verbs last special was fine
you're like you know nothing like it's
also like yeah they have more time to
gossip because I only do 15 minutes a
night right that's more time on their
hands and they're hanging out I remember
this was like I want to say remember
when Jerry Seinfeld was at The Comedy
Store like two months ago this was
recently Jerry Seinfeld like popped into
the Comedy Store
Jerry Seinfeld liesl Oh Jerry Seinfeld
popped in and did this I had never heard
this bit before but it was fucking
hilarious about reason of course he can
make raisins funny and he did this like
long like very good bit about raisins
just destroys right he goes off stage I
go on I think after him or I don't know
who else it doesn't matter and then I go
to town and a pretty known comic it's
like doing old material I was thinking -
whoa dude it's first of all most P
yeah I don't know if it like what are
you doing I know what are you doing yeah
and I remember having this very specific
moment where I was like don't do that
don't do it yeah it is a part of the
brain that's responsible for being a
comedian is being critical judging being
sort of an observer not a participant
because that's what we are we're not
participants in society we're observers
in society it's that simple and we have
to find something wrong with everything
you know we have to find injustice
everywhere right I mean Gary Gulman did
it with sugar cookies like we can we can
make anything offensive that's what we
do so but I think the key is being able
to turn it off when it comes to other
comedians and when we're not performing
or writing yeah I think for me I have
really tried to find something I can
like and respect about most comics even
if they're not like my thing and if
they're not bug you we're not the target
audience exactly where you're buying
tickets you don't have to like anybody
and it's a it's funny I remember Neal
Brennan said once about like comedy
managers and he was like if I was a
comedy manager I would just walk into a
comedy club
ask all the comedians who they hate and
then sign those comments that's
hilarious
that's so fun yeah who do you hate great
I'm gonna go sign that guy right because
every time you talk shit about another
comedian what you're really saying is
why didn't I get what they got and why
don't I have what they have that's right
and you're just it just makes you sound
angry never yeah and it doesn't yeah
even if other people are agreeing with
you
that's just them going I'm bitter - you
don't seem to have a lot of anger I
don't but I've also gotten a lot of shit
really oh my god I've got I mean like
I've been given a lot of opportunities
by the industry if I was like I have
more good news and bad news I haven't
heard about it
really yeah I have a Netflix special
Whitney I know but I'm 26
what's it's a stupid cunt that's the
dumbest thing no I just mean I mean I
got my first special at 26 and I got
like shit don't go online ever don't
ever give something don't ever go but
yourself oh no I would never are you
kidding me okay I think I got my first
question of 26 dad that's what I'm
saying
oh god I was saying do you still feel
that way cuz I'm sure you did oh fuck
yeah I like I feel like I've just always
been all it's like I when I was 26 I
didn't even think no I am I am you yeah
I want the beginning oh oh you you are
you are Italy and I am the United States
and you should be telling me what to
expect
never leave your home ever again maroon
yourself in your apartment for life
never speak to another person and don't
Google yourself under any circumstances
I do think though I think for me it's so
interesting that I didn't put that
together yet cuz I just keep going like
well she's young in a different time
like but it's still so early
that's a dog dog just farted that's
really really aggressively I'm so sorry
I gave him duck eggs don't ask
did you actually yeah I did I wanted to
get him just eggs and I got home and
they were duck eggs
hashtag Los Angeles and so those are
duck egg farm you have no idea how good
you have it bro sorry I think in my head
I just go like oh but like people think
women are funny now like this is a
different totally you know this is not a
gender thing right this is an age that's
right interesting like when you got a
special at 26 and you know
yeah how old was burr when burr blew up
yeah you know what I mean like I think
it's like what would be worse being
successful in having people not like you
or being not successful and having the
respect of comics no you wouldn't have
it then either no I think there are
people who are considered like
underrated or whatever who not what you
want you want to be underrated nope I
would I'll be overrated any day of the
fucking week really yes go and have
everyone hate you sure
really yeah I don't know that I feel
that way if you don't pay my bills I
just don't I can't listen to you
I just not I it's bad business I love
you so much what what I'm here my hero
I'm just saying like you don't I don't
work for you
yeah I work for the people that Plus
press play on the Netflix special and
the people that buy tickets those are my
boss you're not my boss like if you
don't like it that you're not buying
tickets if you bought tickets and have a
problem with the show I will respond you
in the comments I will give you a refund
I will listen to you like I actually
take a lot of feedback from Instagram
and comments see I'm the opposite a lot
of people are like don't read your
comments just fucking fuck that but
you're gonna listen to comedians so
you're gonna ignore the people that
follow you and they could buy tickets
but you're gonna listen to the people
that don't buy tickets oh that's so it's
emo I listen to the comments the people
the Philistines that we all say what the
fuck do they know I mean they must know
something cuz they're the ones that
Ticketmaster I mean they're like it
fells the seats so we have to listen to
them wow I'm a comedian but I take it to
a comedy show that's a very good point
so I'm not saying like what are the you
know about comedy well they're the ones
that consume it yeah I don't know what
to tell you yeah you know so I just I
just I don't know how else to think yeah
so when someone is like oh the fucking
joke logo was kind of offensive or
whatever I'll go like you know look at
that interesting and if a comedians like
that was hilarious I'm like doesn't
matter whoa take it in water off a
duck's back maybe I don't know I wonder
why I feel that way though do you think
you felt differently we were younger all
I care about cool all I cared about when
I was younger was the approval of
comedians okay I cared about I care
about the respective comedians now yes
that's all that is really important to
me yeah that's what I mean because I
want but
but I also know myself I know how I
respond to other people that are doing
well that I'm jealous I like it's just
not a pure form of feedback there's
nothing a comedian can say to you that's
like unbiased saying yeah I'm gonna ask
you a couple more things I don't have to
let you go at some point I really don't
want to because I have so much to do you
have to go I have a phone call tomorrow
yeah I am slammed I have to emotionally
prepare myself for sleep
the nightmares have been insects guys I
have to nap schedule tomorrow I was just
gonna ask you because your podcast is so
you guys talk a lot about self-help like
what's the best advice you feel like
you've heard recently ooh
any good bangers I always like to sort
of bring this up and I also want to ask
about your relation with money since I
feel like you probably you're making
money anything you've learned that you
want to share so with the podcast it's
hard because I was so busy the last
three months and on the road so much I
actually have not been on that many
episodes recently so now in quarantine
Lehner are on this remote podcast like
well Taylor's back like I had just been
like you guys I know I'm not pulling my
weight by the way you're the girl that
disappears when she dates a guy and they
break up and she's like I'm right what
are we doing guys so what are you up to
yeah instead of a guy it was my career
and which is also gone and I was really
like I just can't be on every episode
anymore I had missed a lot of them and
yeah I couldn't even tell you the last
one so the best piece of advice is keep
doing your podcast oh my god stay
connected stay connected we have now do
not become a live touring yeah I mean we
obviously we read like the artists way
which is you know the best I read war of
art and I read intuitive eating in
college and we did an episode on that
cows need Eleni like kind of either I
don't know if they read it or they read
like sparknotes on it but they were like
we do not this does not work for us I
had a lot of food issues growing up but
I would like binge and stuff yeah yeah
and so in college anyone you work out no
I would just binge
in like high school and then I would not
eat like all day come home and binge so
and then I got to college and then I
started losing weight and then it was
like all like thought about was what I
was eating and I got like I was on hole
34 like for months and like you know
were you're just thinking about every
single thing and then I read intuitive
eating I think it was after college
action and I could see how it would not
work for some people it did for what
basic it's just listen to your body and
think about how this food is gonna make
you feel when you eat it as opposed to
your bad if you eat this and you know
you're good if you eat that like putting
all those yeah you know judgments on
each thing so it's it's like very simple
it seems very simple when you read it
where it's just like are you gonna feel
bad the fact that we have a read a book
I know to teach ourselves when to eat
when you're hungry like I love the idea
of people starving in Africa being like
wait there's a book where people have so
not think it's bad to eat just the worst
white girl ever no I mean III did all
that stuff I did the eating naked in
front of the mirror thing for a while oh
my god that's the whole thing I doing I
think there's something to that not the
eating I've never eaten naked in front
of a mirror like I would maybe never but
I have I have sleep naked I have I'm too
scared some shits gonna go down to the
middle of the night you know what I
thought about I think about your body so
much oh my god thank you mean so much to
me I leave shirtless your know your guts
am your boyfriend posted like photos of
you sleeping yeah and it was so funny
and I am fascinated by what people wear
when they sleep uh-huh and I noticed you
were wearing like a full suit and every
was I I wore I were sweat I was wearing
like a sweatshirt in one and it's just
cuz I fell asleep on the couch I dressed
like Annie Hall when I go to bed I put
on a full tuxedo cumberbund vest high up
sneakers like watch with a chain monocle
I am ready to go at any time you get up
and leave yeah I don't sleep like that I
do sleep in like sweatpants and a
t-shirt and what do you think you're
just like one
be ready I want a vigilant I want to be
ready I like sleeping naked when it's
happened but I just the idea it has to
happen
I can't plan people to get roofied how
do we do fall asleep naked you have sex
and then you fall asleep you know it's
you've never fallen asleep after sighs
OH
Oh Andy I'm so worried about you really
that one time what is this a movie never
I have never had sex in his life but you
get all you have to vacuum premises I'm
gonna brush your teeth you gotta pee
after you go cry there's a lot that has
to happen I've never fallen asleep after
sex in the life really yes
you never like gotten up gone to pee we
have to argue about it we have to fight
we have to be like what was that new
move come from that like there's there's
a fighting that has to have like I've
never talking that has to have you've
never slept naked I don't think I have
ever slept naked I mean it is nice I do
get up when I'm in bad relationships or
have been in bad relationships where I
was constantly auditioning for approval
of the other person and worried they
were gonna abandon me at any moment I
would wat like let them fall asleep when
I was naked and then I would secretly
get up and put clothes on and then sleep
and then wake up before they woke up and
take my clothes off to pretend that I
had slept naked like I'm cool girl
this is the saddest thing I've ever
heard in my life I agree that sentence
that sentence if you haven't seen gone
girl you just heard it that that
sentence was the plot of gone girl that
was insane like you would wake up and be
like you put on a shirt I used to wake
up like set my alarm to wake up and then
go put makeup on and then get back in
bed and like be like that in that I've
heard of I have never heard of anyone
full lashes I've never heard of anyone
pretending to sleep naked I wake up at 4
a.m. to contour and pretend this is just
what I look like you know that I've
heard of mmm the pretending to sleep
naked thing is another level brutal that
I didn't know about oh yeah it's nice I
mean sleeping
here's the thing I think I've accepted
that I may not ever have children given
that this ending I just don't know if I
can cuz my anxiety is so bad now and
with everything falling dude here's what
I'll say I'm very fascinated by I know a
lot of people that are in their 20s that
are kind of like is it ethically sound
to have kids what if there's no water
like you know it's kind of an
interesting thing I talk to a lot of
people your age that think that way yeah
that's kind of it'll change when you're
31 and the body starts to take over and
possess you oh when I was engaged I was
following a baby's hashtag on Instagram
and fully crying watching clips of
babies that I didn't know yeah these
were strangers yeah these babies and I
was now on Megan's Law I was weeping
openly hey I like know what's in there
and the a minute I broke my engagement I
was like I don't need to have kids for a
long time I think when you think you
found your person yeah you're like we
should make our stuff we need to
duplicate yeah but when you are not with
your person interesting you kind of go
on birth control I am on birth control
which one Lolo estrin Oh been there I've
been there did you like it you skipped
the placebos or no no can you skip
that's the one that you just honey what
yes the sugar pills I - when I was on
block so I would skip them just so that
you wouldn't have your period oh I take
the sugar pills and I still don't get a
period oh good okay that's what that
time yeah
that's interesting because I've talked
about this before in the podcast when
you're on birth control you're attracted
to a different type of person because
your body thinks you're pregnant right
so you smell pheromones differently then
why do I keep dating comedians lobar
[Laughter]
switch birth controls your faribault low
standards yeah we did we did a couple
episodes on birth control and post birth
control syndrome mhm
because Kelsey and Delaney both were
like we have to get off birth control
yeah and you're supposed to go off birth
control is soon
as you basically get engaged before you
get married to make sure you're still
attracted to the person when you're off
of it because you're attracted to a
different type of person when you're
pregnant than when you're not pregnant
we did not even hear about that yeah
gotta have me on your pot oh my god
auntie Whitney on your pot we seriously
do uh there was on low Estrin and
married the wrong man for her so when
you're pregnant are you attracted to
people who seem stable you're attracted
the kind of person that could help you
essentially raise your child and protect
your child oh they say I don't really
believe in the alpha-beta thing there's
there's really no such thing that's a
confusing concept if you get granular
about it but let's just use those what
you're saying I might be like my body
might be like I'm pregnant and this guy
is home a lot correct so that's good
you're gonna be attracted to someone
who's unemployed yeah when you're on
birth control but when you're off birth
control you're going to essentially be
more turn out by men that take risks
that are more alpha that would be
essentially the kind of genetics you
want to so when you have we you are not
on birth control you are less
responsible in your dating choices when
I was not on birth control I was mostly
dating guys that had tattoos and cheated
yes you're in the essentially alpha risk
taking DNA tall big hands deep voice
that whole deal okay well this isn't
fair because I have only dated on birth
control and I've still been hated on so
I was cheated on by a beta and that's
not fair that is not cool sorry he's
very friendly what's your next podcast
topic I'm sorry we just recorded one
with me and Sam we're know how'd that go
we talked about ah we talked about this
sorry wait Frank come here get off of
her please I'm so sorry Frank Frank
you're so heavy sorry Frank Frank come
here Bubba
OOP sorry sorry yeah watch your okay all
right sorry
you want to come pop out my IUD that way
thank you buddy boy but oh he is going
for it yeah but what was your question
no I was just curious if though the next
podcast that's coming out is I just like
to I like to talk to people in their 20s
and pass on advice they don't need oh my
god like my obligation is that you feel
as you get older you start to feel this
obligation to like pass on things like
as an elder I have your phone number now
and if you think that I'm not gonna be
using it that's true I mean yeah you're
kidding yourself ile like I've become
like the mom like a comedy mom people
like text me all the time like today I
got a text from community was like hey
do you know a lawyer who could help my
friend who's like landlord isn't letting
her have a service dog I was like I love
that I'm the person for this people like
hey can you mix tylenol with ambien I'm
like I don't I'm not a pharmacist I
don't know
why do I get so many weird questions
from people you know I can't believe
people are asking you about making you
know taking ambien and whether or not
they should God don't do it do you sleep
well no okay that me not at all better I
take you good you could be like that
person that falls asleep as soon as you
get on a plane no that's my face being
around again really a lot of people make
a lot of assumptions based on my round
face you they drink a lot of milk on my
glass of lactose-intolerant
no are you um well rested oh my god
thank you yeah I'm not my cheeks are
just fat I just look like a toddler in a
tiara money someone would pay for that
face I know people say that but I
haven't seen any know I'll purge it
later I'm sure it's like when you're a
kid and you're like why don't I have
boobs he had him 15 and then you get
older and everyone's like we wish we
looked as young as you yeah yeah I guess
I'm pretty perky hi I sleep very
terribly I was sleeping so badly up
until like a year and a half ago I was
fully having night terrors yeah I was on
the road you have a lot of anxiety huh
uh-huh yeah take something for it now I
do yeah when I what do you take when I
go got my engagement I got on a I tried
to get on antidepressants and none of
them worked I kept having side if
that were like not bearable and then I
got on a dry cough yeah I think it's
technically a mood stabilizer yeah I'm
on I'm on lamictal uh-huh yeah yeah I
love that so I take that at night it
works great okay and then I was taking
gabapentin as needed for anxiety but it
makes me feel fuzzy and they told me to
take like a ton and once I was taking a
lot it was like making my chest hurt in
a weird way that wasn't anxiety okay
um and then I stopped taking that and
then I take klonopin as needed which I
was very nervous about cuz I'm like this
is why I've never drank or anything
because I'm afraid I'll be addicted to
things but I've actually been very good
with the klonopin and I hardly ever
taking it addicts aren't afraid to be
addicted oh okay that's good news for
you
okay that really oh I'm gonna go home
and get drunk addicts don't ya think
that way you're saying yeah okay that's
you might be addicted to control that's
true or the internal medicine cabinet of
adrenaline quarters that might be that
no I love having the klonopin there um
but I only use it when I like absolutely
when I could tell there's like a placebo
for you just having it is why you don't
need it yeah and when I first started
taking it I was taking it like you know
three times a week or whatever yeah and
maybe for a mouse yeah but I was still
trying to monitor it but that was like
when I was on the road I was going
through horrendous breakup like yeah
happening I was getting on to a mood
stabilizer yeah so now I don't need as
much and then I was in beta blockers hmm
like what made of blockers you might
like some beta blockers for people that
don't want to take up as a
benzodiazepine is that what thrown um
what should be like comma pins xanax I
mean yeah I guess okay not um it's xanax
okay not percocet what's the other I
didn't like XANA what's the other one
Santa's are so great though you can't
function I mean right you you know you
turn into the grandfather from Charlie
in the chocolate iLike it too much which
is why I hate it but what happened you
can you confident right and
beta-blockers basically just stop
adrenaline that's all they do so it
doesn't make you tired it doesn't make
you sleepy it doesn't make you less
energetic it essentially just takes away
your ability to produce adrenaline which
i think is is like you can take it
before you go on stage right
you're not gonna be Leslie he was
telling me about this okay it's you're
not gonna be less sharp if you have to
like go in for a big meeting and you're
sweating like me you can go in and
you're just not gonna get nervous it's
worth it's worth experimenting with
because yeah do it before a show you can
do it before you know that's good
something where you have to be sharp
yeah that's helpful and also I have the
moment purse with me at all times and
again just knowing I have them is part
of why they work yeah knowing you have a
trapdoor yeah let yourself through yeah
I'm sorry panicking yeah and then I got
prescribed seroquel don't know it sleep
at night apparently it's an
anti-psychotic and I take a very small
dose I take half a pill and it's
prescribed for insomnia sometimes it's
prescribed for other things as well I
heard Maria Bamford talking about it in
an interview yeah oh interesting cuz so
the schizophrenia bipolar order of
disorder and depression right but it was
also a side effect as being yeah yeah so
my psychiatrist was like you can take
half one of these pills
grant it it makes me feel it knocks me
out so hard Wow but it makes me feel
kind of low in the morning maybe not
energetic yeah and like a little I could
just sad news no it's hard like right
now then people like they're like I'm
just sad I'm like that's kind of the
before and it was affecting my sex drive
and like I already feel like the mood
Stabler's kind of affect it I first sex
drives supposed to be I don't know
that's the thing it was just different
than before the joke I was doing about
it on stage yeah before our careers got
cancelled was I
people always warned me before I got on
an antidepressant that my sex drive
would go down and I do feel that way now
that I'm on medication yeah but I can't
tell if my sex drive is lower or if my
self-worth is just higher
I guess my sex drive is lower if I've
gotten hotter that's no I can't I can't
tell if I don't need the validation and
yeah cuz like depression will bring you
to your knees and you're like well I'm
down here I'm as well make someone feel
good next I've lowered my standards for
who I've sex exactly exactly it's a
tricky one yeah because I basically
never want to have sex with anyone but
it it's I think it's cuz I bought a
house and I don't
people in it yeah it's sort of like I
think my section I've got lower cuz I
don't have to tell somebody to like take
their shoes off and I'm not as worried
anymore being on a mood stabilizer that
someone's going to leave or betray me
yeah and that if they did I would never
recover yeah so I don't feel like I need
to give as many blowjobs like I I cannot
believe how many blowjobs I was giving
yeah people I was in relationships with
now like no my friends were like you do
it how much I'm like he has to stay so
weird I never talk about that stuff with
my girlfriends really is that do you
guys talk about that stuff yeah that's
so weird
really hi my girlfriends we never talk
about like sex stuff but you never do
Sex in the City brunt yeah we do not sit
and have cosmos and be like so how many
blowies are you giving a week ladies
what I really make um it comes out like
if you go for a long road trip or
something and you start to get bored
yeah I can go through everyone's
playlist and then you go what's everyone
into oh you're fucking - Sheryl Crow
that's your sex list I I'm glad you gave
an example before I did so I knew the
tone Oh Buddha bar Budokan nine people
are gonna get that reference and nine
people in Miami got that I think it's
because a lot of my girlfriend's now are
married and I don't want it to turn sad
you don't you don't do it once you love
somebody in the beginning yeah yeah you
deal with people you're dating oh I feel
like like yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
once you were like this is my partner
yeah I trust them then you stop telling
your girlfriend's details I heard ya
know you can't gossip yep about yeah cuz
that's like a respect but like the first
month or yeah that you're dating you're
like these are the STDs he has oh these
are like this is what I'm basing my
decision making on what did I finish
like you're you're going over all those
things finish in your 20s yeah what I
here's the thing I have a bit about this
in my special I grew up very religious
aha so when I finally did start having
sex it was like of any kind it was like
this better be good because I'm going to
hell now yeah so I was like it had to
shake heaven and earth oh I do not I
never understood my girlfriend's being
like oh I've never liked
I've never finished I was like you're
going to hell and you've never finished
like this is insane like I even worth it
no I'm like I come every time when I the
first time I dated somebody who did not
make me cum and seemed fine with it I
was like you're a sociopath Wow I could
not believe it was so unattractive to me
that's impressive I've been slept with
that many people that's new money that's
new fame that's it that's that's I mean
you should not have impostor syndrome at
all you've not been an impostor at all
my entire 20s was pretending I had
orgasms really I've never pretended I
had an orgasm
what never what maybe that's why I don't
get more acting oh that's why all these
bitches are landing these sitcoms how is
that possible
I mean it I didn't even I didn't even
know because you're trying not when
you're like religious and you're trying
not to have sex and then they're like
trying to get in anyway they it makes
like did you grow up in the kind of
religious environment where it was like
you're allowed to have sex in the butt
no no no I I grew up in youth groups
where they were like is oral sex also
sex and they were like is Chinese food
food yeah idea like that's the stuff
they would say yeah and you'd be like
okay all bats are off the table now
right so maybe that's a more complicated
matter for them yeah I mean they I went
to youth camps and whatever would they
were like you should not be kissing for
longer than 30 seconds you should never
have your tongue involved at all and
your body should not be touching like it
which is perfect for the pandemic yeah
oh maybe they were right abstinence is
something yeah maybe wouldn't we be in
this fuckin mess
yeah yeah so I mean I was trying really
hard to like stay pure and then as soon
as I was I mean I cannot imagine
continuing to be intimate with somebody
feeling as guilty as I did without
having orgasms
like this just doesn't make sense to me
yeah did you go to like a Catholic
school with uniforms no I was Christian
grant okay so I still don't know the
difference between Catholic and
Christian how sad is that
I think cuz I went to both I went to a
Catholic school like very rubber
Catholic school and then like a piss
couple school which I think it's just
everyone's fine as long as you believe
in God you're fine right and then
Christian I don't know the difference
either somebody asked me that in an
interview the other day be like what's
the difference between this and this and
Methodist and I was like I don't know
man I just know that in my house the
bottle is a test any dicks yo don't even
touch it
that's that sex if you touch one like
there was no room for this isn't
technically yeah like you know the
minute I was sexually active in any way
yeah I was like well it's word it's done
that and I still waited a while to have
sex because I was like well there's one
thing I'm saving where do you stand with
God now I don't know I hope there is one
now oh my god it's and I'm look I do the
higher power thing like I'm fine with
saying God it doesn't upset me it
doesn't I think you can still believe in
science and like I'm not as anti God as
most people are yeah I'm not anti
religion either because I think to be
anti religion is very classist quite
frankly hmm for a lot of people that's a
way to socialize it's a way to hang out
it's a way to get child care like yeah a
way to keep you know I'm Pro Scientology
keep them in a building keep them all in
one building so we all know where they
are
I'm fine with that go be friends yeah
like you all get it otherwise the cults
gonna be all around us yeah well you
know I'm fine with them keep them in a
building maroon them they've been in
quarantine for years but I it's
interesting how when something I don't
pray really much but when something bad
happens I am talking to God like when
one of my dogs had sick I was like okay
God it always starts with I know it's
been wife right yeah are you still there
I think he's like a man with a
microphone and headphones I'm like I
know and I apologize for how long it's
been
yeah cuz in my head God like keeps a
like a ledger and he's been waiting for
you
and all he needs it apart this all
accepting God's needs me to over
with an apology right and it's always
like I'm sorry it's been so long right
things been crazy I do like the idea of
God with his feet up on a desk eating a
sandwich and reading a paper and then he
hears your voice comes and you're like
he's like oh shit oh yeah Whitney what's
up I'm sorry I didn't think you were I
didn't think you're gonna do this again
I gotta wrote you off a while ago sorry
my mouthful also I love that in my hands
he can hear me but didn't know I was
busy right I've been really busy things
have been crazy I've been slam you know
me you know me you know I am you made me
like you of all people know this like
I've sort of like cherry-pick yeah what
he knows and doesn't know
and then I and then I start bartering
I'm like you can have my car yeah you
can take my house like as if he wants me
to like hit as venmo yeah so that my dog
stays alive and I start telling God all
the things I'll give him to not let my
dog die
yep yeah I've started doing that too
where I'm like I will say more commonly
I will I will pray for what I want and
then when it doesn't look like I'm gonna
get okay okay all right okay yeah meet
you halfway I see where this is going
I'm not an idiot fair let me get ahead
of this yeah so okay so it's it's not
gonna work out fire me I quit yeah okay
so he's so he's not he's not going to
love me the way I deserve okay okay
you're trying to make me stronger I see
what you're doing is you're doing I see
what you're doing I would just ask that
you um speed it up so this this last
less time this suffering you're giving
me a new closer I said this is a test I
see what's going on okay thank you thank
you thank you God but if you could just
refund my money yeah it's just so weird
I how many times I have prayed I pray in
the last year I said if there is
something better that you are trying to
the goal the rejection is God looking
for my go if that's what's going on here
could we speed that up the good thing
that's coming I'm with you I'm all-in I
just needed to have been faster yes
that's all I just can't be here that
long
I'm surrendering to God's will as long
as it's on my turn
yes 40 years I can't do it maybe eight
maybe eight years no that's our
attention span I'm a millennial I'm a
younger we watched MTV Cribs like where
our attention span is just quicker I
can't take this I'm dying yeah I'm
excited I'm gonna die at 34 yeah so I
know that you make those decisions but
this one I feel like is up to me look
it's all in your hands and you know
what's best and everything to your plan
pitch
I just have a pet but if I could just
what seem what I think what seems like a
good idea to me yeah is that I know you
have the best ideas but you also made me
therefore I probably have some good
ideas too cuz I'm in your image so let
me pitch something back to you that
makes more sense
it just feels like coming to like your
abusive boss total he's gonna give you a
job or delay at the newspaper when your
internship is over I have to let you go
at some point I was gonna ask you if you
knew what a hypo color shirt is hypo
colored hyper color is that the one
that's all scrunchie and it gets really
small the shoulder and it looked like it
was made of a thousand nipples made out
of a used tissue it was so bad it was
like a tiny shirt that would look like
it would going a doll and then you put
it on and it stretches out yeah it looks
like you balled up a piece of paper and
threw it yeah this is a shirt that was
in the 90s that was if you sweat through
it it would change colors you know it
was Carson night for everyone that you
know that has cancer got it from those
jobs is the first time I found out how
my mom died it was like Taco Bell or
something but a lot of closure from this
vodka how would you describe your style
I mean when a stylist isn't my best
[Laughter]
best I can to I think put together what
unassuming yeah yeah I think I'm afraid
to look - I like simple and hopefully if
you feel like you need to cover yourself
yes I'm always hydrogen I've always
thought that about you that I'm always
covering well because I used to do that
a lot - and I still do I still do yeah
but it may be just cuz when I see you I
feel like you it's not like armor but
it's like this is okay yeah agree no it
is like it is and I see it because
that's I'm like that too but it's like
I'll see you and you're like your
leather jacket and like that's your
comfort zone yeah like it's like a
little bit of a second skin yeah if I
were a hoodie onstage I'm like ooh look
at us I can I will not show my arms on
stage nope never can't do ever done it
can't do it wouldn't why would you I
would you what world thank you bizarre I
know I could never do it but I also just
like the consistency of the same thing I
know I'm know I mean I said I tried to
wear corduroys onstage recently that
were like kind of bell-bottom and cute
split him really bent over split him I
was like this is why I were the same
thing on stage every single night I know
it's not gonna rip I know how I'm gonna
be able to move I know what I can do
with my hand
why mix it up yeah there's something to
that'd be great
who know you know that episode of the
office where Jim is putting quarters in
Dwight's phone so that it'll just build
up the weight and it'll take them all
out and then it'll hit him in the face
that's what I feel if I like just
stopped wearing a jacket on the day that
I would gesture too freely and just like
boomerang back and hit myself in the
face because I'm like oh I'm not used to
no weight on my arms really funny when's
your birthday November 4th I don't know
anything about that shit
I'm Scorpio now we're just hanging out
what are you do you know what you are
Timber forth do you know what that is a
Virgo okay which ones that I think
that's good I think I say that's people
like oh you're so chipper virgo is like
calling someone a cunt at this point
lazy kind of go scorpio really yeah
everyone's like you are like people who
know your RPO basically it's like saying
you're a vindictive asshole oh is that
what scorpions do yeah Scorpios are
supposed to be like very like into
vengeance
and sexual manipulation okay which I'm
like yes well Christian vixen over here
and I definitely am petty is that weird
I definitely hate you I know it's just
funny because like whatever somebody
wants to accuse me of being like too
much of a Virgo and I'm like why and
they start listening and they're like
because you're always so busy and you're
never around and you're never available
I'm like oh I just want to hang out with
you yeah this isn't a verb no I make
time this is you thing yeah I think
virgos and Scorpios are pretty
compatible though I think we're
similarly intense yes I only know that
because somebody asks Sam and I on IG
live and he's a Virgo Oh when's his
birthday
I think it's August it's late I don't
wanna say the wrong one best yeah very
anal-retentive I guess well it's cuz
it's also I mean I have a whole theory
about this about it's not about the
month you're born it's about essentially
the other holidays that existed and the
same month you were born and what other
things you had to compete with oh so Sam
and myself your boyfriend and I we both
had our birthday basically around the
first day of school that we had to be
academic on our birthdays like my
birthday was September 4th I was in my
first day of school when it was my
birthday I was working on my birthday
that set the stage for the type of
person I was gonna be okay Oh simple
like and then Leo's that are August you
know late July August are in the summer
they get to have their birthday party on
vacation they're outgoing you know they
got to have birthday parties and be the
center of attention so they got used to
it you know I was competing with
Halloween and Thanksgiving didn't have a
chance didn't have it you had to become
funny you had to become intense yeah he
had to be vindictive and manipulative in
order to get someone to pay attention to
you oh my god you're right and then
January might they're about January
capricorns just like they're also very
academic very serious work really hard
they had birthdays but no one had any
money left after Christmas and New
Year's and no one had time to celebrate
their birthdays in January that's when
we're back to work you need to write
another book I very the moon and the
stars according to it I feel like that's
why I like in your most impressionable
time what you had to compete with on
your birthday is what forms your psyche
how have you not written a book called
Whitney
come into my office I mean that to me is
my favorite advice I've heard in a while
just pretend to believe in yourself yeah
because it's also like that's my thing
about any people that have low
self-esteem especially actors and
comedians and like I'm so insecure I'm
like pretend you're not yeah nobody
thinks you are act like you're not yeah
do you mean and then let you're also
pretending you're faithful to your wife
and we're buying it it's true pretend
you believe in yourself and I like the
people who fall in love with you slowly
find out that you or a crippled mess of
anxiety you're pretending you can afford
that car why can't you pretend to like
yourself for five minute oh my god
that's so true that's such a bummer how
many male comedians cheat on their
partners I mean look it's such a bummer
to me it seems like it's waning a little
bit I mean when I started it was yeah I
mean it was flagrant when I started
stand-up well now anyone you sleep with
on the road could reach out to be or I'm
a correspondent yeah
Entertainment Tonight absolutely you'll
get a book deal and that can find your
wife on social media that's right and
met like yeah you're gonna get caught
it's it is it does a little bit feel
like those days the jig is kind of up on
cheating in general yeah oh I don't know
I mean it is insane to me that people
still cheat because I'm like you will
get caught it's exhausting it's it
sounds so exhausting yeah but I also I
also understand I guess why mm-hmm
particularly male comics cheat or like
any male performers yeah because they're
not worried about safety yeah on the
road and they're getting so much thrown
at them yeah because yeah if it's that
easy
you're gonna come by it's so easy to
cheat now easier than ever but it's
easier to get caught exactly but let me
ask you a question because I always
think about guys that cheat or people I
know I'm almost like the life must know
I'm Matt yeah I'm always like so I mean
you were cheated on I've been cheated on
did you know yeah I did and the
and he lied to me about it for years
gasps let you or did you lie to yourself
um no I think I knew and like you knew
in your heart of hearts yeah I just knew
my gut oh yeah when he'd lie about other
stuff he'd lie about like small things
the way you do anything's the way you do
everything no one lies about I'm five
minutes away when they're 20 minutes
away and doesn't lie about other shit
yeah exactly that's exactly what it was
and we were on and off for like years me
and that guy
and he yeah he just always told me that
I I was like that he would never and he
didn't and all this stuff and like it
got to a point where I felt so crazy and
so bad I spent like years like
apologizing to him I mean I have jokes I
have jokes in my special saying that guy
never cheated on me I just thought he
woke Sabine crazy in my special that
just came out I hope that guy reached
out to me the week before I filmed my
special to bury the hatchet and let me
apologize over and over and there were
things they did that were not cool damn
where I would break up and get back
together with all but that's I mean it's
not you don't but a lot of it was like I
don't trust you and you're you keep
lying to me about stuff and I just know
something going and like whatever it's
there's other things involved too and
I'm not like that's about people crazy
people make you feel like you're crazy
right yeah and like he has his own stuff
and it's fine but he you know what what
made me so angry is that he reached out
before my special and I even told him I
was like just you know like I'm really
sorry I do jokes about you in the
special and I say like you never cheated
on me and like all the stuff and he's
like it's totally fine wandering to the
bridge whatever like a month or two
afterward finally admitted to cheating
on me and I was like what like are you
character you were broken up no I he he
and I had been broken up for a long -
when okay yeah yeah it wasn't it wasn't
my fiance it was a different guy that I
had dated on and off for like the first
four years of my 20s yeah yeah so this
is what your 20s is for this stuff but
that guy is kind of why I mean not
totally but like a little bit of why I
got engaged because after that guy the
last breakup would that yeah I went out
with my ex-fiance like days after yeah
and what I was like I was like I am the
next person I'm like I'm getting over
this guy and then who
right date next is just I'm not putting
up with a shit anymore and it's gonna be
the guy and I think I just kind of like
ignored some red flag course and you
know maybe just was like this is gonna
be the thing and and I thought these are
the things I need and it's the opposite
of dating a comedian and blah blah blah
and and also when those red flags went
off in my head I didn't trust my own gut
NIEM yeah oh gosh been there yeah so
like I and I still felt that way after I
broke up with my fiance which is when my
other ex admitted to cheating on me
years ago it made me go oh my god I was
right to call off my wedding too because
I've been here before yeah but I had
been in that like post called off
engagement state going am I just insane
like am I just crazy because I I felt
this way with that last guy and I think
I might just be imagining it with people
now cuz they keep insisting they're not
doing anything even though they're lying
to me and I can see that they're not but
is it just me and I also think that
people like us like comedians who have a
relentless loyalty to the truth at all
costs like we're not afraid of the ugly
truth like we that's you know we love it
yeah I think it's it's so funny because
I grew up around like pathological lying
like I've been and not a lot of those
relationships people lied to me when
someone it never occurs to me that
someone's lying lately I just it's
seriously like I cuz I just don't know
why anyone would like it's just to me
like such a waste of time and energy so
I agree but I think everyone's lying and
also I have lied I've done my fair share
of lying and I hate the way I feel when
I do it's such an intolerable feeling of
shame and it's exhausting which just you
know what any sensitive person would
feel after lying anyone who's not a
sociopath that I just like I can't
imagine someone would want to carry
around a secret carrying around his
secrets a full-time job so I just assume
everyone's telling the truth all the
time cuz I'm like why wouldn't it just
seems it's so 90s
I assume that everyone is lying all the
time
and it almost takes somebody admitting
something horrible to me for me to go oh
they're oh they must be telling the
truth yeah at that yeah but I always I
always say that to be I'm like
however if you mess up just tell me yeah
because it you'll get more points with
me yeah I'll go wow that was really hard
that you admitted but it also then it
gets and then it gets tricky cuz
someone's like hey I cheated on you and
you're like thanks for telling me it's
like I know but you it'll be bad but we
can work through that we're a little bit
in a time where if you do something bad
and apologize it's almost you get more
points that if you have never done it in
the first place yeah like that's the new
thing is like but wait you think you can
get over cheating you can work through
cheating I think that if somebody it
would depend on the obviously they're
sorry I think there are certain I think
there are certain circumstances like if
you sleep with my best friend no but if
you like if we've been together we've
been podcasting for three hours my dog
my dog is obsessive Taylor you guy said
I cannot get him off of her you get over
being cheated on Frank he said you never
never never when he does when people get
feel stressed out or have any kind of
anxiety or he starts to you know get on
them here's I think if I had been with
someone for a long time and they messed
up and they came to me immediately and
we're like this is what happened and
they felt really bad then I could maybe
work through it because I would because
it would prove to me save you some time
no I wouldn't
auntie Whitney coming in hot look maybe
you're a better person than me or maybe
you're the generation I mean I know
people in their 20s that are fully in
open relationships and right I I would
never
I'm like that's new that's a new thing
Frank come here sir my leg hurts so bad
buddy I love you I don't know what that
is I know people your age that say the
same thing you're saying to me right now
cannot fathom it maybe it's an age thing
I am so black and white about that shit
because I I believe that in order to
cheat it takes time to cheat it's not
you don't just go to a bar see someone
and your dick falls in it like it's
it's--there's texting there's flirting
there right you know what I mean like we
all know what it's how long it takes to
sleep with someone or to have someone
sleep with us there's no true there's no
such thing as a one-night slip because
it always takes some kind of build up in
an investment of time and energy and you
had a lot of times to change your mind
yes we've got like a hooker which is a
whole other thing
and that's probably an adrenaline
addiction or something you don't think
that's more okay this is gonna be a
polarizing take get right now three
hours in because if if this poor kid of
me in relationship with someone who's a
sex addict that's a legitimate real yeah
addiction and you're in relation with
sex I mean I know people that are in
relationships with sex addicts that it's
like that's cheating of course but
that's almost like slipping on drugs and
alcohol not easier it's much easier to
have someone slip on drugs and alcohol
but that is usually not like a choice
and a neurological thing and the genetic
thing so it's slightly different than
someone that doesn't have an addictive
personality choosing to go cheat on you
and spending a lot of time and energy in
it I understand that so bad still bad
here's what I will say if there's money
involved it's not here's the thing as
somebody who's been in that situation
yeah uh I was not I can I can wrap my
head around why someone did something
once someone tells me I'm like like that
guy admitting it to me you're so nice
I'd them admitting it I was I was angry
about being lied to for years yeah that
was what I was mad about the cover-ups
worse than the crime the fact yeah the
fact that I could I could wrap my head
around why he did what he did I was like
totally I know you really well I know
why that happened I know the
circumstances but I just don't hell are
we together I mean I got oh like on and
off by the time he'd misstep I don't
even know it was I just here's what I'll
say you're what 23 at the time
Lucille's cheating on a 20-year old that
looks like you is a mentally ill person
that's an ill but they're also young had
you had you turned hot yet have you
turned yet no okay it's just I was just
cute I just mean like that is to me
that's an ego thing that's someone who
just doesn't have self-control cos to me
cheating forget the sexual part and
having to imagine how horrific that is
it's also just like like you're not in
control of yourself and that's not sexy
yeah self control and restraint is hot
to me yeah I think people but I think
everyone cheats on I think everyone
cheats on hot people I think you ought
to say everyone cheats on everyone no no
no I think I think people cheat of not
because they're like oh I want to have
sex with that product I think they cheat
because they feel it's an its new he
doesn't matter but I just mean like
they're bored or they feel inferior and
their relationship or their mentally ill
how would someone have gotten bored of
you I mean how long were you together I
mean it was we hadn't been together that
long and we were young yeah and I don't
know we were together so many times that
I don't know how many times it happened
yeah their thing yeah so and at that
point you've lied to me for so many
years I'm like you could be downplaying
how much you cheated on Annie could be
lying to yourself you might not even I
mean I've I've been with someone that
cheated and I'm like I in when he would
lie to me about I'm like I think you
believe what you're saying absolutely
that's what the craziest part of this is
is you don't know you're lying
yeah I I think the indiscretions that
you can even conjure up right now like
are half of the story yes or they tell
themselves that they're protecting you
by not they go what what good would it
do for me to tell you that would just
cause you pain it would ruin our
relationship like I don't know how many
you ruin it yeah yeah no it's gonna know
that you've made that decision and those
people don't realize like yeah I'm gonna
I was doing a joke about that in my new
hour to when I was touring I was like
like if you did something just tell me
because I'm gonna know you did something
well and I'm gonna create something in
my head that will be so much worse yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's interesting because
to me as soon as I am like let me see
your fault it's over you know yeah as
soon as I'm feeling any of that as soon
as any of these conversations are
happening I'm like it's over
yeah questioning any of it and my whole
thing the cheating is like if you want
to cheat don't blame you just tell me
and let's break up mm-hmm and let's make
it a breakup where you dated someone
else yeah sort of like let's make your
cheating not cheating yeah like if you
find yourself being attracted to someone
else and you like just tell me I halt me
on the way over I'm a big girl
I can handle it yep I don't blame
someone but just tell me and then we can
maybe get back together if it works out
later we'll go date other people for a
while and if it you have to be it's
meant to be cuz there's a thing them
telling you either that I'm attracted to
somebody else I'm gonna go see where
this goes we're all attracted to
somebody else right it's all everyone's
attracted to somebody else the game
isn't are you attracted to someone else
it's how do we go through life resisting
fucking everyone yes that's what we're
both signing up to do yeah we're the
best no I'm giving up people - yes
you're not the only person giving stuff
up yep we're both we're both passing on
a lot of people and choosing each other
every day and by the way not just having
sex with other people having rich full
life with other human beings it's not
like I don't catch a fuck anymore yeah I
could have been an investor's wife I'm
missing out on fulfillment yeah I'm it
head-on traveling those are different
live eautiful countries yes I'm giving
you my life yep yep and that maybe not
better but just different there are lots
of people I could have been happy with
yeah so you have to make sure you really
like hanging out with that person so for
me the cheating thing is like if you
tell me that you cheated on me I take
that as you respect me enough to be
honest with me what I can't forgive is
you thought I was stupid you weren't
trying to like keep me safe for protect
our relationship or like I was just so
afraid to lose you no you were afraid
that you're gonna you were on that yeah
you were afraid that you I was gonna be
mad at you and you were gonna have to
deal with consequences yeah of your
actions so I think that's the difference
to me is like either way you did a
terrible thing in one situation you take
responsibility for it and you show me
respect by saying I'm gonna tell you and
be upfront with you yeah and then
another situation I would let me I know
here's where I would I would say if
someone is I'm happy to be wrong here if
like the mentality of like you're
respecting me by telling me you don't
respect me if we're in this situation at
all Oh interesting you if you respect to
me we wouldn't be having this
conversation but I think sometimes
people cheat
they don't feel good enough for their
partner then you're not good enough then
you're not because you're not yeah
you're not good enough for me
yeah we I agree yeah we agree on you
just proved it yeah yeah you're not good
enough and like that's okay
I took me a long time to stop confusing
love and pity mmm like I don't if I pity
you that's not the same thing feeling
sorry for you
get out of there yeah it's like Oh your
feelings of inferiority like okay I want
someone who is wildly better than me yes
I do not som want someone that is worse
right you know any like oh I'm at it
it's know that it's incest I'm your mom
but yeah I do think it's like I'm so
zero tolerance about that I I mean I had
to let it get so bad mmm you know I mean
the stuff I've seen in phones folks
brutal I've never gone through anybody's
phone the most I've ever done is go show
me your text with this person in one of
me I'm gonna go through your phone
didn't go great he kept me he's super
still I heal emojis no no just like
making plans with somebody he said he
didn't make plans with summer and you're
like it's over like yeah say like even
if you didn't cheat on me you lied about
it so you are going to over like what
are you and it's it's taking me okay my
dogs farting is getting out of control
no I do think and look maybe this is the
wrong advice and people are in
quarantine and they can't leave as soon
as you're saying where have you been
what was that like it's over right I've
met you I don't think you can come back
from it yeah yeah I just don't think you
can yeah I agree
you know although you know being touring
comedians there's always gonna be some
days that you're like hey where are you
why didn't I hear from you for 20
minutes and it's like okay we're both in
you know shitty cities and yeah you're
being a little weird yeah like what
sometimes it is just you're also a
little weird riff isn't he in what way
like I'm so I've only met your boyfriend
once I was so endeared by him weird that
he's so nice oh he's just like he's very
nice he's very engaged like I I was
weird like I I at first I thought he
didn't like me and then I was like hi
we've never met before and he was and
then he was
so nice and only he's so nice he's like
so nice it's kind of does that ever make
you insecure about how I see all I've
ever wanted was the guy who's nice and
then you date someone who's nice and
it's like well are you this nice to
everyone
they probably thing you're flirting oh
I'll be too nice I don't feel that way I
do this with this is not a Sam thing
this is a me with everyone thing yeah
when I start dating people anything nice
they do I'm like this is your move this
is how you do it I just go like what did
you do just tell me really
flowers out of nowhere what did you do
let me see your phone oh wow you're
worse than me
see I don't think they did anything yet
I'm just like all right this is how you
operate is your bed this is what you've
done for everyone great and then they
have to then convince me and then
sometimes it is so bitter like Richard
Pryor DVD but this is what you do for
every girl you date like no you're
comedian I thought you liked it I know
the fucked up thing though is sometimes
it is their move like sometimes that's
what they do by the way what do we not
want them to have dated anyone right
it's like oh and you've never done
anything that you've done for this
person I'm like yeah but you also have
done some you've yes you've done some
reason your spot yeah you have your
Jersey they bring out to show you're a
cool girl it's like and maybe this is
just bird's-eye view from being like
older like you want a guy who's dated a
lot of people not been cheated or
womanized or been abusive earning that
you want someone because it's other
women have done some work for you hmm
you know ii mean consider them your
teammates I consider X as my teammates
hello like thank you for whatever
training you did yeah thank you now
we're passing the baton I'm inheriting
you know it's like getting a dog for
like adopting a dog from another family
it's like you taught about it so you're
talking about a dude like thank you no
there's still more work to do but I like
to see X's as like sisterhood but what
if they would have they abused your dog
and you're like now I can't shut the
door - without freaked out keeps biting
me yeah now every time I shut the door
they think I'm leaving that's on you it
barks at all women yeah
peed on my leg I think it depends I mean
there's definitely times when you're
like having sex with a guy in the
beginning and you're like okay I just
learned a lot about your ex right right
what she's into but don't have that
thing we're not doing that here uh-huh
or it's like I just I know everything
about her um now we're gonna start from
scratch she trained you very well yeah
well and was like almost too
communicative about this right um but I
do I think that we don't want to be with
people that have no relationship
experience true such a careful balance
and then I used I used to feel the same
way that you did about feeling insecure
like oh if they find anyone else
attractive yeah then they're gonna go to
them and ya know we're all attracted to
other people and it's fine that's
healthy it's noise all being normal took
me a long time especially the religious
roots I mean my parents are like Mike
Pence level we don't have lunch with the
opposite sex alone like they are you
want people to go to all these women are
hot and I choose you exact thats what
you want exactly you want someone that's
dated a lot of people so by the time
they get to you they can actually
appreciate you mm-hmm
you know if you're the only person
someone's ever been with great mm-hmm
like you're the like best of one right
exactly that's 250 yeah I want to go oh
you could have all these women in your
choosing me or you have dated all these
people now you appreciate what I bring
to the table cuz you have something to
compare me to right exactly that's the
healthy way to look at it mm-hmm right
yeah my therapist would say don't say
that don't say healthy say helpful oh
really why is that I can't say that's
not healthy oh you say that's not how is
it's a judgment on yourself that's not
healthy just say like oh kind of helpful
oh I know so much oh so much there's so
much to talk to yourself gently she gets
really into the words we use and makes
me substitute words with judgments on
them and and the things that sort of so
slowly chip at our soul mmm remember one
time because I think self-deprecation is
something we could go to a lot anyway I
remember time I was talking to her and I
was like I'm starting to stutter which
means you know we have to wrap this up I
have like carpal tunnel of the tongue
and I was talking to her and I was like
oh you know whatever I hate myself I'm
so stupid I can't believe I did that and
she was like what is that and I was like
what do you mean she's like what is that
thing where you call yourself stupid and
you hate yourself knows oh no it's like
I'm a comedian like that's how I
punctuate my sentence no it's that was a
period it's the constant refrain yeah of
my life and I was ago no I just say like
I hate myself like it's like it's funny
and she was like it's not that funny
your shoes just like I'm not laughing
like really uncomfortable when you do it
and you're like well it's worked for a
lot of audiences just sold out in
Pensacola yeah so what do you know about
the comedy business but it was funny
because it made me realize like oh I
think I thought it made people like me
more when I degrade myself yeah if I
make myself smaller they don't think I'm
like full of myself and it doesn't like
I found what other people do it I'm just
like oh no yeah now do I have to ask if
you're okay yeah okay what a delight you
are I love talking to you you are oh my
god I'm just fun are we friends now I
feel like we're best like we're really
good you're my best friend
never letting you leave my bucket or
break my legs like misery there is no
cell service at Whitney's house by the
way for everyone listening and zero and
there's you know the password right I
want you to connect yep no it's gonna be
like what was the movie see your
references misery what's the one boxing
Hellena this was a movie that famously
Kim Basinger which was attached to and
she pulled out at like the last minute
and they sued her
it's like a whole SOG I read about an
Alec Baldwin's book and that was just
fascinating to me because I like
sometimes you get attached to projects
and you're like I wonder what happened
if I quit like what are they gonna sue
me like they can well you're signing a
contract that says you have to do this
job right and it was a I can't believe I
loved playing the game of like can you
believe that moving I made this was a
movie about a guy that was so in love
with his some woman and he was a surgeon
and he cut off her arms and legs and
kept her in a box oh my god
quarantine viewing why the fuck would
you tell me that I'm just telling you
someone was like this was their dream
project they wrote the script they went
out and pitched it like that person
should be put down you know how long it
takes to get a movie made like when I'm
like why was the
the thing you wanted to spend three
years on that was your vision boxing
Helene a 1993 mystery thriller with
horror elements directed by Jennifer
Lynch starring sherilyn fenn with horror
elements sleek back this was just a
romantic comedy Oh squirty says he loves
me
starring sherilyn fenn Julian Sands and
Bill Paxton some of these people are
dead the plot follows a surgeon who's
growing obsession with a woman leads him
to amputate her limbs and hold her
captive in his home after she suffers a
car accident
Oh gained notoriety before its release
after protracted legal battles with
Madonna and Kim Basinger both of whom
backed out once they read the script
debuted at Sundance Film Festival
received critical praise what after
receiving an nc-17 rating yet no shit
watching a guy fuckin abdomen is that
movie banned if I almost give it an R
rating on appeal release the United
States in September 1993 but then
received critical backlash it was a
financial failure I think this is what
we're watching tonight Oh Mike I have
one more question before we wrap oh my
god geez sorry you don't have to I mean
I mean I mean we why not my question for
you is have you been the type of person
that during this time has wanted to
watch things like outbreak and contagion
no okay all right no no really left me
alone on those zero zero mm-hmm this is
where our friendship ends I know this is
that was so that's pretty confident
you're gonna make it maybe if I haven't
said this the entire podcast and I think
I need someone needs to write me a check
when I was your age I finally said it I
I think I would have but I have gotten
it so hammered my therapist doesn't let
me she basically is like you cannot
watch that shit the way your brain works
you just can't see I haven't seen
Chernobyl I can't watch it like that it
fucks me up for weeks
Chernobyl did fuck me up but that's just
cuz it made me think about death
I always think about death though really
Oh cuz you oh all the time every day
interests yes oh I
every day I'm think about death if
things are going well I'm like how do
you think you're gonna die
I think I'm gonna get sick like do you
think we all know how we're gonna die no
gone to our heads no I don't think any
of us know yeah gun to your head how are
you gonna die here I get shot in the
head
here's my thing anxiety wise I try to
worry about everything huh so that it
won't happen because I feel like what
you worry about sense of control yeah
almost never happens at least not
exactly that way kind of person and
here's what I'll say I think there's a
war on worrying there's a war on anxiety
and I'm always a person thing that's
like anxiety does serve a purpose it
protects you the most anxious people in
the tribes are the ones that really is
that a lion is that a lion and they got
out of there and they survived right
Aaron Oya served a very important
purpose in our reptilian brains and in
tribal times now it's just some of us
have a little too much of it just
directed at the wrong things right you
know we were worried about getting
wrinkles when we should have worried
about a virus yes I was worrying about
the wrong things this what I'm saying
though I when I worry about everything
whatever I don't worry about is what
ends up happening
I had worried about literally everything
else I was like the big ones gonna hit
you know a family member of Mines gonna
die I'm gonna die I'm gonna get in a car
accident like I thought of all these
things that could happen around my good
news which was that I had a special
coming out yeah and none of those things
happened the one thing that happened was
a pandemic that threatened not only the
business as a whole but our entire world
and I think I didn't think of it because
I didn't watch contagion because to me I
was like that will make me spire I'm not
gonna watch it that'll make me spiral
that's never gonna happen and now I'm
like I should watch it so that I can
prepare or something it's like something
where I can prepare yes like I don't
know and like they don't find a vaccine
at the end of contagion I looked it up
yes took him an hour 40 minutes hour 40
right Americas comfort I literally got
to where I was like can the person that
wrote contagion get involved in this
yeah they can the Hollywood
screenwriters that have been spending
years researching pandemics they
probably know more than a lot of people
the administration right now they
actually know a lot can the guy from
house yeah
it was like the consultant yeah for
house get in here
yes stop him in do don't you feel like
Tom Hanks is gonna be fine right yes so
don't you feel like that makes people go
it's okay Tom Hanks had it and he's fine
and in the same way watching a movie
about the same thing where at the end
everything works out you're like okay
everything's gonna be fine I feel like
the moment I thought we were saying the
dog is it dollar really on one he's on
steroids so things are really hitting
the fan um I think that when I heard Tom
Hanks got it that's when I was like
we're all gonna die really got to dummy
yeah oh I know this doesn't care about
it went for our leader they went for the
guy yeah for America's Sweetheart
yeah and this is something that does not
discriminate I think if Tom Hanks had
died the entire world would be on
lockdown
Oh we'd be we would have just I mean I
would have jumped off a balcony
it would have been voluntary just messed
aside everybody would have taken would
be taking this so seriously yeah but a
lot of people are probably like Tom
Hanks I know they're like why would I
cancel spring break yeah it's it's
interesting to see who because a couple
other celebrities have it I mean it's
yeah it's the thing with like football
no one's gonna care about concussions
until like Tom Brady likes his neck no
one's gonna give a shit you know what I
mean it's like all that stuff what a
delight Celaya
you're gonna like this is how long did
we go almost three hours really three
more than three hours oh my god amazing
it is 9:00 p.m. it's nine o'clock at
night you oh my god here four hours ago
makes me so happy I don't have cell
service my boyfriend thinks I'm dead
just tell me you're cheating on this
honestly this will probably be good for
our relationship is that I'm always mad
at him for not being worried enough that
I'm dead I met it all my boyfriend it
stills it's it's not too late yeah yeah
Mike were you afraid you know Whitney I
know you I need the Wi-Fi password yeah
except or just ask for it and oh how do
I ask
well like go to the Wi-Fi network let me
have it you guys want to hear us get
Taylor on Wi-Fi
I mean people are boarded this is what
quarantine content is first orders
fucking post mates on his podcast so
we're allowed to do this um okay I'll
get you on okay
um Taylor listen to her podcast she's on
it now mm-hmm self helpless self
helpless and special on Netflix
yes quarter life crisis you think she's
halfway through her life yeah I thought
I was I thought I was now I think I'm
80% done this is the last podcast she'll
ever do before she passes on you know
what to do I don't know all the stuff
Benton says normally subscribe all that
you noted you're an adult you know you
know how this works if you haven't done
it by now you're not gonna do it
don't write elephants if you can donate
to servers and service people that have
lost their jobs please do any amount
counts Yashar Ali is my friend who
started I should have been prepared with
this sorry started a great thing to
raise money i tweeted about it just go
to my twitter if you guys can give to
that just a little reminder i gave to
that as well
and now i'm just rambling i love you
guys say strong say strong I'm really
tired
text me three - three - nope
eight one eight two three nine seven 57
I'm gonna stop talking I always have
been Lee's and these very awkwardly I
[Music]
[Applause]